Three, two, one and we're back.
What's up? How are you are back.
I love it. Good. Nice to be back
here. When you first came here,
you were thinking about running for
president and now you're out there.
We're all in. It's happening.
Yes. Nervous. No. Is it
weird? No. No. Not at all.
Do you feel like this is like destiny?
No, that was enough. Feel weird.
I'm on a mission. I'm on a
mission. Uh, you know, there,
there's a lot of issues I think
we're going to talk about,
about why I'm running for president,
uh,
but being out and connecting with
people all across this country,
bringing this message, um, really
of, of ending these wasteful,
destructive,
a foreign policies that have been so
costly on the American people for so long.
Cost the, on our troops Casi on our
veterans, ending these wasteful regime,
change wars,
ending this new cold war and nuclear
arms race and taking the trillions of
dollars that we've been spending on these
programs and that we will continue to
spend if the status quo is allowed to
continue and investing those dollars back
into serving the people.
In our communities serving
the people of this country.
Things like health care,
education, infrastructure,
protecting our environment,
clean water.
There's so much that we need to do.
We've got limited resources
to accomplish that.
These are my favorite things
that you talk about. Um,
my question is always though,
why do we spend so much time and money
and at such a titanic human costs.
Yeah.
For these rigid regime change wars,
what do you think is the cause
like other than the obvious,
if we,
you have a dictator that's in place,
there's an obvious outcry like Saddam
Hussein post nine 11. Other than that,
what is,
what is the reason why we invest so much
time and energy into regime change war?
So much so that we've just accepted that
this is a part of our gross economy.
Like if you're going to take all the
money that the United States earns and all
the money that goes to taxes,
we just automatically put a gigantic
chunk of that into investing in these wars
in other countries blindly.
Why is that?
Almost without any kind of
traditional real accountability. Uh,
six to $8 trillion is what's estimated
that's been spent since nine 11 alone on
these regime change wars without even
taking into account what the cost will
continue to be to take care of our
veterans, those who have gone and,
and fought in these wars and have
come home dealing with, you know,
visible and invisible wounds that,
that they'll have to live with for,
for the rest of their lives. Let's start
back. You mentioned Saddam Hussein.
Uh, I don't think it was necessarily
an obvious outcry. Saddam Hussein,
uh, and the toppling of his
regime was done for oil, right?
It was done for financial reasons and
the architects of that Iraq war, uh,
sold it in the guise of, hey, Saddam
Hussein is working with al Qaeda,
those terrorists who
attacked us on nine 11,
and he's going to give them his
weapons of mass destruction,
both of which turned out to be false
false intelligence and lies that were sold
to the American people, sold to
soldiers. People like me, uh, who,
who believed what they said. You
know, I enlisted after nine 11,
like so many people in this country to
go after the terrorists who had attacked
us on that day killing thousands of
Americans and they sold this lie,
uh, for financial gain for oil. You,
you look at some of the architects of
that Iraq war, guys like John Bolton,
who today is president Trump's
national security council director.
And you look at what's
happening in Venezuela,
almost the very same playbook
being used or they're selling this,
this regime change effort,
uh,
threatening to use US military force
to go in and topple a regime under the
guise of humanitarianism.
When in fact in Bolton has said this
on national television that well,
we really want to make sure that American
oil companies are able to go in and
access that oil rich country in Venezuela.
So you think that's why there's so
much turmoil in the country right now.
This is this battle over regime change
because of the fuck they want to control
the oil.
I think the,
the u s coming in and trying to insert
itself into what is happening in
Venezuela is what is, what is the problem?
So they're doing that through a very,
very heavy sanctions.
Uh,
they're doing that through various means
and threatening to use our military to
go in and topple the regime there rather
than taking the approach that I would
take as president, which is to
recognize that the people of Venezuela,
like people in other countries in the
world need to be the ones to determine
their governance and their future.
Just like we wouldn't want any other
country to come in and threaten to use
their military to topple our government
or to tell us who should or shouldn't be
the leaders in our country. We shouldn't
be doing that in their country.
There are a serious issues that are
causing a lot of suffering for the
Venezuelan people.
If we really want to be helpful,
we should be a force to help move towards
reconciliation and peace rather than
what this administration
is doing, which is, uh,
throwing fuel on the
flames of a civil war.
That will be devastating.
Devastating.
When you say move towards reconciliation
now, well you see there's differences,
right?
There's the people who are
with the current government
in Venezuela and there is
the opposition. Clearly they have
differences on what kind of future,
what kind of governance and who
should lead that government, uh,
going forward rather than
threatening to use the United States,
the United States coming in and trying
to act once again as the world's police.
Uh, which by the way, throughout
history has not had good results,
not for the people in those countries.
What to speak of the cost that, uh, we,
the American people pay. Okay.
Rather than saying, hey, let's,
let's work towards peace,
try to push for diplomacy and find what
are the conditions that would make some
form of reconciliation,
uh, going forward. Is
there an argument, and I'm,
I really don't know the answer to this,
but is there an argument that these
regime change wars, although terrible,
we would be way worse off
if those weren't in place.
I think that's an argument that proponents
for regime change wars try to make,
but history shows and proves
that the very opposite is true.
Look at Iraq. You can look at
Libya, you can look at Syria,
you can look at Guatemala and Ecuador.
You can look at other countries, uh,
Iran,
where in the past we have either
overtly or covertly through the CIA,
gone in and toppled, uh, leaders of
countries are dictators or regimes.
And the result has been more suffering
for the people in those countries.
Their lives have been made worse off,
not only in the short term but
in the long term. And the cost,
once again to the American people has
also taken a toll as we see more and more
of our hard earned taxpayer dollars
going to pay for these wars. Uh,
these regime change efforts
that are counter to our
national security interests,
counter to the interests of the American
people encountered the interest of the
people in those countries.
So is this one of those things is just
a counterintuitive thing where you would
think that getting rid of someone
like Kadafi would be a good idea?
He's a terrible evil person,
but they get rid of them. Now.
Libya is a failed state. It's,
it's horrible what is happening.
And Livia as a result of that, as you
said, watch slave auctions on youtube.
It's insane.
Exactly.
It's hard to imagine that
an era of Youtube and slave
auctions exists in a place
that,
you know,
at least some part of the blame has to
be on supporting the rebels that went in
and took out Kadafi like
it's not good to have. See,
it's one of those counterintuitive things,
right?
Where it's not good to have an evil
person in control of a country,
but it's also not good to kill
him. I think. Get rid of them.
And then this power vacuum,
right?
Yeah. It's that, um, it's,
it's hard to accept sometimes the reality
that there are bad people in the world.
Yeah. There are leaders of countries
who are doing bad things against,
there are people.
What the real question is,
is we recognize this is the
world that exists in reality,
not the world that we wish existed.
And then the question is for
the leaders of our country is
what role should the United States play?
Does it make sense to try to
act as the world's police?
As we have been for far too long,
both as we look at what is in the
best interest of the American people,
what's in the best interest of our
national security as well as, uh,
what impact will our actions have
on the people in these countries?
And with Libya, not only do we
see strengthened terrorist groups,
there are terrorist groups all
over Libya now failed state.
The Libyan are suffering, uh, now
far more than they were before.
But we see the ramifications of that in
countries like North Korea where again,
John Bolton in the Trump administration
is talking about using the Libya model
with North Korea as we work towards this
objective of denuclearize the Korean
peninsula.
Uh,
one of the leaders in the North Korean
government just said the other day,
the United States government is talking
about using the Libya model with North
Korea to get them to get rid
of their nuclear weapons.
They don't want to end up like Libya
or Iraq. Where in Libya is you?
Remember the United States
went in and told Gadhafi, Hey,
get rid of your nuclear weapons program
and we're not going to come after you.
And he did.
He got rid of it.
And what happened a very short time later
the United States and other countries
went in and took him out.
So that action in that decision,
that policy is directly undermining our
national security and our efforts to
make us and the world more safe to
denuclearize the Korean peninsula.
So would the argument for
regime change wars being that,
would it be that if we didn't go over
there and if we didn't have a military
presence and we didn't
make them fight against us,
that they would somehow or another
gain more power and they would,
we would deal with this
evil superpower is this,
there's this like the worst case scenario
for the pro interventionist foreign
policy.
I wouldn't even, I wouldn't
even go that far. I mean, the,
the argument that's made by people who
are advocating for these regime change
wars is we've got to do something
to help people who are suffering.
That's generally the
argument that's made a,
and they sell this to the American people
knowing that, hey, we, uh, we have,
we have good hearts and we
want to help people if we can.
But what they fail to do is to tell the
truth and be honest about what they are
hiding behind this guys of
humanitarianism, right? I mean,
if you look at Saudi Arabia for example,
and you look at the kinds of atrocities
that, that theocratic dictatorship, uh,
is conducting against its own people,
decapitating Lgbtq people
persecuting religious minorities,
uh,
being the biggest propagator of this,
this most extreme intolerant ideology
of Islam that is fueling terrorist
organizations like isis and al Qaeda
waging a genocidal war in Yemen killing
tens of thousands of people. Uh, you know,
that murder of the journalists in Turkey,
the list goes on and on and on.
Yet, what are we hearing from
leaders in our government,
both Democrats and Republicans?
Saudi Arabia is a great
ally of the United States,
but then you look at what's happening in
Venezuela ready to launch our military
to go in and take out another dictator
ready to go in and launch our military
ready to and wage a war against Iran.
So this is,
this is evidence of the hypocrisy that
exists between those who are waging
regime change war in some countries,
by the way.
Usually countries that don't have nuclear
weapons and usually countries where
they have some other underlying
interests and ulterior motive,
which is not helping the
people of those countries.
And then when it's convenient for them,
countries like Saudi Arabia sidling up
to a country whose leadership directly
and indirectly supports al-Qaida the very
terrorists who attacked us on nine 11
who we are trying to defeat.
W
your position on Syria is one the,
I think people have misconstrued.
Why don't, why don't you tell
me that's putting it nicely.
That's trying to put
as nicely as possible.
They've actually said that
you are an Assad supporter.
I know this is not correct.
Yeah.
But is that one of those things where
people just say that in order to sort of
diffuse you to categorize
you as a ridiculous person
right off the bat where no
one can take anything else
you say? Seriously? Yeah.
It's, it's the usual tactic of, uh,
trying to smear or vilify
me and my campaign and,
and what I'm advocating for,
uh,
because they don't want to engage on the
actual issue itself that I'm pointing
out about how devastating and costly
their policies are of continuing to wage
these wasteful regime change wars of
choosing to support terrorist groups like
al Qaeda in Syria directly
in Syria because they are
the most powerful force on
the ground who's fighting to take
out the regime Assad's government.
So they're so focused on toppling this
government in Syria that they're willing
to actually use taxpayer dollars to
provide direct and indirect support to al
Qaeda terrorists in Syria.
When you think about how
crazy this is, uh, it,
it makes me angry.
I think it makes most people angry.
It's why introduced legislation
called the stop arming terrorists act.
Why we would need to have
such legislation is beyond me,
but it clearly we do to make it so that
we don't have any tax payer dollars
going directly to provide any
kind of arms or support or,
or anything to terrorist
groups like al Qaeda,
but also to make it so that we're not
providing support indirectly through
countries like Saudi Arabia
who are providing that
support to terrorist groups.
So what, what has been said
of you about Assad then your,
your position on Assad?
That's just been an outright lie?
Uh, virtually everything. I
mean, I'll just tell you what
happened. I went to Syria,
uh, to, to meet with Syrian people,
to hear for myself from them
about what was happening there.
A while there I was offered the invitation
to meet with the president of Syria
and I took it because I
think it's important for us
to have the courage to meet
with leaders,
whether they be friends or adversaries
or potential adversaries if our focus is
on national security and on piece.
So I went and I had that meeting and
I asked some tough questions and uh,
heard from him his perspective on what
was happening and what he was doing in
his country and took the opportunity while
there to meet with religious leaders,
college students, members of the political
opposition, small business owners,
um, you know, women who are working to,
to start their own business, to empower
other women, Shia, Sunni Muslims,
Christians, Catholics, people
of all different religions. Uh,
it is because of that and that meeting
and my staunch opposition to regime
change wars in Syria and
in other countries that
political opponents and others
have chosen to try to smear me
my reputation and my campaign.
Uh, and to label me as you said, you know,
she's a supporter of this dictator. Well,
if that's true,
then anyone who opposed the Iraq war
is a Saddam Hussein lover is a lover of
dictators and love Saddam Hussein.
If you challenge their logic,
you see how shallow it is and
there's really none there. And,
and what's exposed is,
um,
their refusal to engage on the facts
and to stand behind why they continue to
put the American people through these
costly regime change wars and why they
continue to wage these wars that are
causing incredible suffering for people in
different parts of the world.
Know it also, when you're having these
conversations, which are incredibly,
incredibly important globally,
when you choose to distort
people's positions like this,
you're not helping anybody.
No. You're making the whole
thing more confusing. Yeah.
So for someone like me who's
on the outside, excuse me,
and then has to watch all this go
down, I have to go, well, why, why,
why do you have reasonable people that
make inaccurate statements about someone?
Because they feel like if you do not,
yeah.
If you don't refuse a meeting with Assad,
there's something wrong with you, right?
Yep. To not want to be in the
presence of this person. Yeah.
Yeah. I mean, the, the, um, there's so
much hypocrisy around this. You know,
a lot of these people are the same people
who applauded President Obama when he
first ran for president in 2008.
Uh, when he, I mean he did,
he caused some controversy
at that time saying yes,
he would meet with the leader of Iran
without preconditions that he would meet
with leaders of other countries in that
pursuit of national security and peace.
Yeah. So why the double
standard here? That, okay.
So in order to keep our country safe,
in order to achieve peace,
we're only gonna meet with our
friends and people who we agree with.
That's not how you
accomplish that mission.
That's not how you accomplish security
and peace. It doesn't make sense.
Circles, social version of running
the world, sadly, sadly. Now,
had you ever met anyone like Assad before?
Um, no. What was that like?
No, he was eager to meet.
He was eager to be heard,
frankly.
Does he speak English
very well? Really? Yeah. I think
he was educated in Europe, um,
at dentist, if I'm not mistaken.
Uh, it's in the middle.
Maybe he's an eye doctor is not in the
medical field. Hmm. MMM. And he was,
you know,
he was open to,
to any and all questions that I had
both about what was happening, uh,
in Syria, uh, you know,
serious relationship or the
lack thereof with Israel.
A lot of the,
um,
turmoil that we're seeing in
different parts of the Middle East of,
of Sunni versus Shia.
MMM.
Chemical weapons being used. Uh, you know,
criminal acts being conducted,
a whole host of these issues.
How do, how, how, uh,
the Syrian government is dealing with the,
the Kurdish population in the
northern part of the country.
What's going on in Turkey? There was,
there was a number of things that, uh,
you know, I, I asked and he answered
and he shared his view and perspective.
And really what came out of that was he's,
um,
he's very narrowly focused on his
country and doesn't want other people,
countries,
or other people coming in and,
and a meddling in their
country and what's, what,
what there trying to accomplish,
which is actually the same thing that I
heard from his political opposition when
I met with them. These are some of the
leaders who, who led the protest that,
um,
that kind of began this whole conflict
in 2011 people who are deeply opposed to
the Syrian government,
some of whom have been held in
captivity by the Syrian government.
And they said there are constitutional
changes we want to make. Yes,
we would like to see Assad removed from
government that they don't want to see
it done through military means or through
other countries coming in and toppling
their government.
What they want to see is that change
coming from the people of Syria saying,
hey, this is the kind of leadership
that we want for our future.
I can imagine there's not a single country
on earth that wants us to invade and
take over. I mean, it just seems
like a bad idea for everybody,
right? Nor nor would we
want that to happen to us.
I think that's really what's
missing here is, you know,
for so long we've seen this
imperialistic mentality, um,
that still exists in our government
where some feel like, hey,
well we should go and tell this country
who should lead their government and
tell them what kind of
policies they should have.
But no other country should dare
even attempt to do that to ours.
Well, our position is that
we're the best and we're,
we're running this country the best way
and this is the best country that's ever
existed, ever has the most
freedoms. It's got the most,
it's got a lot of things going on. It's
not, they're not good, but yeah. Overall,
yeah, we, we feel like we're the
shining light of the world. Yeah.
Maybe that's not accurate. You know,
maybe it's accurate in a lot of ways.
And Yeah,
I think the problem,
the problems begin when we go into other
countries and try to create little mini
America. Exactly. And impose it on the
people there, whether they like it or not,
whether they're ready
for it or not. Uh, and,
and we ended up seeing what we're
seeing across the Middle East.
Yeah. I think we just looked at
the rest of the world and go, well,
I wouldn't tolerate that. Yeah. Why are
they tolerating that? Who is that guy?
Why does he get the road thing,
say should kick his ass?
That's literally the American perspective.
But you know,
we don't want to send our sons and
daughters over there to go do that for the
[inaudible].
Do you know if I put my tin foil hat?
We don't, we, the American people don't.
But this is the problem,
and this is,
this is something that I realized very
quickly during my first deployment to
Iraq where I was seeing
firsthand the cost of war,
serving in that medical unit
every single day. And I,
I wondered how many politicians
in Washington who voted for,
advocated for champion that war in Iraq.
We're laying away at night awake at night
thinking about my brothers and sisters
who are getting killed in combat,
who were getting severely wounded
or getting blown up, eds and I, I,
I learned very quickly,
uh, that they were not,
they weren't thinking about the real
cost and the ramifications and the
consequences of their decisions.
Jimmy,
who are we talking with the other day?
We're trying to say that we think that
if you want to be the commander in chief,
that you should probably
have served who was a,
is the reason podcast CT Fletcher.
Yes. I believe that it was him. Yeah.
Who was a veteran as well. Hmm. MMM.
That's one thing that you have over them
for sure is that you understand from
firsthand experience and sacrifice what
it means to actually be in war and in,
to be in combat.
Yeah.
Yeah. I mean, over,
I still serve in the army national
guard now over over 16 years.
I've deployed twice to the Middle East.
And, uh, coupled with my experience in,
in Congress serving over six years on the
foreign affairs and the armed services
committees working intimately on these
issues related to national security and
our foreign policy meeting with leaders
of different countries in the world. Uh,
it is these experiences
and the understanding that
I've gained from them that
best equip me to walk in the door,
walk into the Oval Office on day one,
ready to do the job of president. And
most importantly, commander in chief.
What hurdles are you encountering
that you didn't expect?
Uh, you know, a lot of what's
happening are things that, that,
that we kind of did expect, you
know, the, the smear campaigns, the,
the misinformation campaigns
that someone's doing on purpose or do
you think this is team mentality and
action where people are supporting a
particular candidate and they look at you
as being competition, that candidate?
Like what do you think is hot
combination? Um, you know, I'm,
I'm challenging the establishment,
challenging the status quo,
challenging the foreign
policy establishment, uh,
and challenging the political
establishment in calling things.
As I see them calling it straight and,
and speaking the truth,
whether that be calling out leaders within
my own party or leaders of the other
political party. And, um,
I think that that strikes fear in a lot
of people who are uncomfortable with it
at a minimum and who are
concerned. Because when, you know,
we, the people rise up and say, hey,
what's really going on here? We're,
we're calling out self serving politicians
in Washington from both political
parties who are putting
their own political interests
or the interest of their
party ahead of the interest of the people
where they're putting the interests of,
you know,
whatever greedy corporation in their
lobbyists is writing the biggest checks to
there campaigns ahead of
the interests of the people.
So the more this awareness comes out,
the more people stand up and speak out
and say, hey, this is unacceptable.
This is unacceptable.
Then it's threatening that
very power base that they,
um, have, have thrived and
lived off of for far too long.
We should talk about how you're funded to,
to so people understand your position.
Yeah.
People powered campaign. We
take no, no PAC contributions,
no lobbyist contributions.
Every single dollar that comes to my
campaign for president is coming from
individuals,
people across this country,
whether it's a dollar or $1,000, people
who are giving whatever they can, uh,
and joining this movement.
There's a great joke.
I've,
I think it's from Dennis Miller hope
I'm not misquoting it, but it's,
he was talking about how politicians
where patches on their jackets,
like Nascar drivers that is like,
you should have to know seriously.
Yeah.
So what should housing claimers there?
What if I put my tinfoil hat on when
I talk about these interventionists,
foreign policy wars and and
regime change wars. The,
the tinfoil hat thinks military
industrial complex. Yeah.
People being asked or forced into making
decisions that benefit these giant
corporations that makes,
make weapons and profit off of war.
This is the worst case scenario
in terms of conspiracy theories.
The idea that someone wants war so that
they can make money and they don't care
if people die even needlessly. This is
our number one conspiracy fear, right?
If you had to think about
of all the things that you
hope are not true about the
way the world works,
that would probably be number one.
Well,
you can take your tinfoil hat off because
the military industrial complex is a
real thing. This is something that, um,
President Eisenhower talked about,
which is an amazing, amazing speech.
Has his last speech. Yeah. As
president of United States,
all the things that he could talk about,
he chose to focus on the military
industrial complex. Should we,
how dangerous though it is.
I feel like we should play this just
cause it's literally play that clip.
It's so crazy in most people
have never heard it before.
And you hear about the term military
industrial complex and one thing that has
been done that's really, really
interesting is the word [inaudible].
Bureaucracy has become a dirty word
and that dirty word or a word that
[inaudible] it's, it's easy
to make something silly by
calling it a conspiracy.
Yeah. Even though there are times
where people conspire to do things.
That's right. I mean that's
why that word exists, right?
It's not like people don't make plans
to do things that are illegal. Yeah,
of course they do it.
That's why the FBI's around and yeah,
but this is from the national archives
and this was Eisenhower's speech,
has he?
He was leaving office
leave taking and farewell
1961 not getting very much attention
when a new press was this Guy Jamie,
you picked up the wrong version.
Son of a bitch. I'm sure there's a,
an actual version of it. Yeah. Here we go.
Chill on January 17th,
back when everything was black and white,
the president of the United States.
Good evening,
my fellow Americans.
We now stand 10 years past the midpoint
of a century that has witnessed for and
made your wars among great nations.
[inaudible] this is a bad
one to Jami son of a bite.
While he's looking for the right clip.
What?
I think he's just going to
play music in the background.
That's all it's gonna do.
What most people don't know is that his,
his first draft of that speech said
Congressional Military Industrial Complex.
Whoa.
And somewhere between the draft
and the speech that was delivered.
He took out that word congressional,
but he was directly connecting
those dots that some may say,
oh,
well that's just a conspiracy theory,
but he was connecting those dots with the
influence that the military industrial
complex has on leaders in Congress who
are making decisions about how our money
is spent and where our troops are
sent off into battle. Gresham tunnel,
congressional military industrial complex.
Wow, I need extra foil. Get you a new box.
Well, I know it's crazy. Or they couldn't
keep the camera steady back then either
voice. Here it goes. Good. Are
you doing my brother one? Skip it.
I had a couple of seconds. A vital element
in keeping the pieces are military.
Establish our arms must be
mighty ready for instant action.
Show that no potential aggressor may
be tempted to risk his own disruption.
Our military organization today bears
little relation to that known of any of my
predecessors in peace guy or indeed
by the fighting men of World War II or
until the latest of our world conflicts.
The United States had no armaments
industry American makers of ploughshares
could with time and as
required make sardines as well,
but we can no longer risking emergency
improvisation of national defense.
We have been compelled to create a
permanent armaments industry of basketball
portion had to do this.
Three and a half million men and women
are directly engaged in the defense
establishment.
We annually spend on military security
alone more than the net income of all
United States cooperation corporations.
Now,
this conjunction of an immense military
establishment and a large arms industry
is noon in the American experience.
The total influence, economic, political,
even spiritual is felt in every city,
every state house,
every office of the federal government.
We recognize the imperative
need for this development,
yet we must not fail to comprehend.
It's grave implications.
Our Toil, resources, and
livelihood are all involved,
so he's the very structure of our society.
In the councils of government.
We must guard against the
acquisition of unwarranted influence,
whether sought or unsought by
the military industrial complex.
The potential for the disastrous rise
of misplaced power exists and will
persist.
We must never let the weight of this
combination endanger our liberties or
democratic processes. Okay. We
should take nothing for [inaudible].
Right. You can listen to the rest
of the speech if you want to online.
But it's very chilling.
Yes.
Because this is the sitting president
leaving office and this is what he wants
to tell people. And a soldier, yes.
He's a guy who had military experience.
He's the guy who saw firsthand wearing
the uniform and then serving as commander
in chief. And this was his
final warning to the nation.
The military companies
are like most companies,
they always want to grow.
Companies seek infinite growth.
They're constantly seek
better quarters every year.
They want to make more
money than it did last year.
That's what they're doing there.
They're in the business and making money.
They're not just in the business
of creating things. They,
they're creating things for profit and
they're gonna have a little wiggle room.
And especially with politicians,
politicians that are in their pocket
and they've spent millions of dollars
helping them along the way. Yeah.
Yeah. And you know, they're gonna,
they're gonna help each other. Yeah. And
this long history of helping each other.
That's right. That's um, I mean you, you,
you see that very directly through
contributions that are being made,
uh, to politicians by different
defense contractors, the
corresponding votes that are then taken.
Uh,
but you also see this corruption
that's happening before our very eyes,
uh, happening within places like the
Pentagon where you either have people in
uniform or civilians who are working in
contracting, for example, in the Pentagon,
laying the groundwork for
writing up these contracts,
major multimillion dollar contracts
with these big defense contractors,
and then lay down the uniform
or you retire from service
either as a civilian or
in the military,
and then you turn around,
leave that door and walk into another
door working for the very same contractor
that you just wrote the contract for two,
this is happening. This is what,
this is what we need to change.
And we're talking about both
campaign finance reform,
but also reforming this kind of
corruption in this revolving door that's
happening in different
parts of our government.
You see it happening in Wall
Street to the SCC regulators.
People are supposed to be regulating Wall
Street or coming from Wall Street and
then going back to Wall Street to work
for the very same companies that they
were supposedly just charged to regulate.
This is a big problem
that we've got to fix.
It was a fantastic documentary
on that called inside job. Yeah.
It's amazing.
Yeah.
You see when he's confronting these guys
who are professors who then go and take
these jobs and make millions of dollars
with the very regulations that they help
put into place. That's right. And it's
happening with foreign policy as well.
When you look at who,
who are the main people who go and
testify in front of Congress, uh,
coming from think tanks, very
well known, think tanks, uh,
global think tanks that
specialize in foreign policy. Uh,
they don't have a placard on,
on their desk when they're testifying
before Congress saying we receive funding
from Saudi Arabia, from cutter,
from United Arab Emirates,
from all these different countries who
are spending a lot of money funding these
thing takes that then come forward and uh,
push policies or push ideas to leaders
in Congress that not coincidentally
benefit the countries that
are funding them. What,
what could be done to stop that other
than someone like you getting into power?
Well and what could you do once you get in
there? I think, I think two, two things.
I mean obviously as as president
and commander in chief,
you set the tone for the
kind of leadership that we
have in this country that
will put service above self and this is
what what I will bring us present and
bring those soldiers values of
putting service above, self,
putting service to the American people
in your country first and foremost ahead
of everything else,
of head of the interest of a political
party or a corporation or or a foreign
country for that matter and work to
pass legislation in Congress that would
close these revolving doors that
would require this transparency.
When you're talking about who is funding
and where is this money coming from,
I think members of Congress should
not be taking pat contributions,
should be relying solely on contributions
from people in this country so that
they know exactly who is funding their
campaigns don't really seems like a no
brainer.
Yeah.
That one seems like a no brainer and
it's something that the people want.
It's something that that's starting
to happen organically as more and more
people, uh, are calling for this
kind of reform and saying, Hey, look,
if you want my vote,
then I expect you to not accept those
contributions and to run a people powered
campaign. How many people
were doing upside to, uh,
there's a couple who are
running for president.
There is a slowly growing number of
people who have run for and got gotten
elected to Congress. Uh,
but look, it's, it's a,
it's in the margins compared
to where we need to be. Now.
One thing that exists now that really
didn't exist when Obama was running for
president is the impact of social media.
It's just tenfold what it used to be.
But with that also comes this reality
that we're living in right now where
there's only a few companies that are
controlling the discourse in this country.
Yeah. I mean, you really have
essentially a Facebook, Google,
youtube, Twitter, and Facebook
owns Instagram. That's
right. And there's, you know,
a couple of other small ones, but
that's the bulk of our discourse. Yeah.
What concern do you have about these
private companies controlling the vast
majority of communication between
people on social media? Yeah,
it's extremely dangerous. It's extremely
dangerous when you think about it.
And there's a few things.
There's gosh with,
with Facebook and Google for
that matter. You know, they,
they can set their algorithms,
uh,
Mark Zuckerberg with Facebook and said
his algorithm to control what information
is coming across our newsfeed in Facebook.
What are the stories that we're seeing?
Instagram, same thing with Google.
They can control when
you punch in something,
what are the first stories that you're
going to see a on the first page that
pops up?
Uh,
when you think about that kind of power
of influence that has on the American
people literally being held within the
hands of a couple of people unchecked and
without oversight or transparency,
it's incredibly dangerous.
Talk about free speech.
There's just been news recently about
Facebook banning certain individuals,
uh, from having Facebook
accounts because of their speech.
They disagree with the
speech that they're,
they're using are the things
that they're talking about,
ideas that they're pushing forward,
unchecked first amendment rights going
completely out the window and monument is
a don't apply because it's a
private company, right? Yes.
But they're trying to get
the best of both worlds. Um,
the fact that that, you know,
they're claiming to say, hey,
this is a free space for open
communication for everyone. Right.
While at the same
time going and saying,
actually, you know what Joe,
I don't like what you're saying
about this. So we're going to ban you
and
whoever your friends are from, from
this conversation. Um, I think that's,
that's a big problem at undermines.
It undermines our first amendment
rights and you look at privacy,
the privacy concerns of all
the information that they're
collecting and Facebook
from us, all the information that
they're collecting from us, uh,
with Google and how they're monetizing
that and selling or sharing that
information with other people
with really without our,
our knowledge or agreement.
That's the part, right? The,
the agreement that most people didn't
understand that your data is a huge
commodity. That's right. And
we signed up for these things.
And who reads terms of service
agreements? Have you ever read one? Yeah,
I've never read one of them.
I just say, okay. Yeah.
I started to get through like the
first two paragraphs. Like, okay,
I'm going to hope it's not ugly.
Nothing terrible.
You know what I think back to there
is a south park episode that that is
specifically about the terms
and conditions. And uh, I just,
I hadn't watched it a long time ago,
but every time I see one of those
things pop up signing the terms things,
I'm like, oh man. Yeah,
that was Carmen, right? Yes.
Yeah. You can't talk about it. Um,
okay. But there's, there's
a thing that they're doing.
There's a couple of things we're doing,
but one of the things they're doing
with this, um, with your data,
they find out what you're interested in
and they find out what you're interested
in engaging on. Yeah. And for
many people, that's outrage.
So for many people it's the
things that piss you off the most.
Like if you have a real problem with
Catholic priests getting away with having
sex,
a little boys,
you will think that that's
happening every minute of every day,
all across the world.
Because it's going to be in your news
feed constantly because they know that's
what makes you engage. Right. So your
algorithm, the algorithm is your,
your feet is going to be very
different than my feet. Yeah.
Cause I engage on different
things than you do.
And the problem with that is
even if they're not calculating,
if it's not on purpose, they're not
trying to get people outrageous.
Not only that, trying to rabble rouse,
but what they are doing is they,
because they have an ad supported model,
they gravitate towards the,
the outrageous. Because that's
what people get excited about.
And that's what people
make multiple posts about.
And that's how they make their revenue.
It gets a bad ad model.
It's an an ad model that
inadvertently supports outrage. Yeah.
And it makes people think the world's
worst planner and all of that. And this,
the tribal boundaries between the,
the two sides on these
issues are more tense.
And you would think that discourse and
the ability to freely communicate would
kind of open that up and people would
kind of understand each other better,
but it's not happening. It's like think
Twitter is a garbage fire all day long.
It's just fire.
Like you can't post anything
about anything and there's
people just jumping on
people and yeah,
it's,
it's a crazy thing that has happened
that we gravitate towards the outrageous
yeah. I don't think should be rewarded
financially. I think that's not,
if this is just what people go
to organically, that's one thing.
But when you're cultivating feeds,
so,
or at least your algorithm is cultivating
feeds so that people get pissed off,
you're making the country
a shittier place. Yeah.
Like you're literally like
making things worse. Yeah. Yeah.
I mean this is one of the reasons why,
um,
I think a couple of things
should happen. And, and uh,
I think his name is Chris Hughes who
cofounded Facebook with Zuckerberg.
Saw that. Do you see as article calling
for Facebook to be broken up? Yes.
And which is crazy.
You hear about the person who founded it
and he's saying this is out of control.
And that's the point right
now is seeing how powerful,
as you said, guys like Mark
Zuckerberg have become and uh,
and how out of control things are. Well,
some of it just doesn't make sense.
Like here's one they just
banned Alex Jones. Yep. Not
only do they ban Alex Jones,
but you can't talk about Alex Jones.
If you wrote Alex Jones might be nuts,
but damn,
is he cute of you wrote that it would,
you would get a message that says,
only you can see this message.
This message is stopped at the border
from entering into the Facebook universe.
Like what?
The fuzzy,
you can't just like what have
you want to say something funny?
You can't say something funny.
No,
you can only say something if
you're criticizing him. Right.
This is what they've said.
It's telling you how to think,
which is fucking insane. It is insane.
Because that's not just Frisco.
That's not just like a
violation of free speech.
You're literally directing
speech. Yeah. Like that's insane.
So you're,
you're,
you're not even blocking people from
doing something hateful or evil.
You're blocking people from saying
something that you disagree with.
That's right. Which is, people have
sent me messages that said, uh,
God bless Alex Jones and they say,
you can only see this message.
Facebook sends them a thing blocking
that message. Wow. That's fucking crazy.
Like the idea that you think you can do
that. Yeah. That is nuts. Yeah. I mean,
being able to ban anyone
arbitrarily without any just
violated terms of service.
There you go. What does that mean?
Yup. Okay. Be specific. And how come,
I mean they've, they took a
bunch of people out, right?
Like Louis Farrakhan was one, Alex
Jones, Paul Joseph Watson was like,
what did that guy ever do? I mean,
people don't agree with them.
Like I think what's happening is there
was some serious concern that Facebook
was used to influence the last election.
Again,
whether against their knowledge or in a
way where they were negligent about the
type of filtering they use that stops
people from posting propaganda and
particularly stops these
things like the IRA,
the Internet research agency in Russia
that literally creates thousands of
profiles and pages and they'll have
a black lives matter page that's
just designed to fuck with cops.
And then they'll have a procop page is
just designed to fuck with black lives
matter.
All they want to do is create anger
and they're doing this engineering,
these arguments. I mean this
is, this is 100% proven fact.
Renee de Resta,
who had been on my podcast went over the
details of how it's set up and how they
do it and the means and
the means that they create.
Like this is an organized effort that
they channeled through Facebook in
particular. And then Instagram and
a couple other social media sites.
You know what's interesting about Renee,
she worked for new knowledge, right?
I do not think she was the
director for new knowledge. MMM.
They this company new knowledge that
the DNC has tapped as one of their,
um,
I don't know,
disinformation campaign experts in cyber
experts was the very same company that
created false accounts and pretended to
be Russian bots in order to influence a
US Senate election
in Alabama. Yeah, I'd
heard of that. Right.
So something that she
was not a part of it.
Yeah, I know. I don't know her.
She's a director of research,
it says at new knowledge.
Right.
Okay. And that, but that's post
this happening. Correct. I don't,
she sent me an email about it cause I
questioned her about it after it happened.
Yeah.
And I don't think she's full of Shit.
Yeah. Well, I, yeah,
I, I've never met her,
but I know that that company is
one that is often cited as, as,
as a so called expert. And it
was a company that was cited, um,
uh, to try to smear my campaign
as somehow being a, uh,
an engine for the Russians or something
like that. Which, which to me again,
just points to, well, let's
look at, let's look at the x,
the so called experts that
you're citing in this company.
New Knowledge and the kinds of
actions that they've been taking,
the very same ones that they're
criticizing others for doing.
It's a dirty world out there for a
while. The last thing, the Internet,
it is a wild west in the sense that,
I mean I think there should
be regulation like, I mean,
I don't think you should be able
to put child porn everywhere.
I don't think she'd be able to dox people,
but it's like where does that border stop?
Yeah.
Where does that regulation border stop?
Yeah,
and I think it's a very good question.
Do you think that these
social media platforms,
whether it's Google or
Twitter or whatever, Facebook,
do you think that they should be treated
as a public utility where everyone
essentially has the right to use them.
You have the right to use water.
You don't have the right to take a hose
and smash your neighbor's window and
flood his house.
I do.
I do think that they should be regulated
like that and they should be subject to
the very same antitrust laws that have
been used to make sure that we don't have
other monopolies in other industries
or in other areas, uh, to,
to, to break them up. And I think
that was something that, uh,
that Chris Hughes outlined in his article,
the furry first step that could be taken
is just to say, hey, you've got a, uh,
you've got Facebook needs to let
go of Instagram and what's APP?
Because that was [inaudible] that that
acquisition created an even stronger
monopoly that really shouldn't have been
allowed to take place in the beginning.
And so there are, there are concerns
about the kind of power being, um,
you know, consolidated into the
hands of a very few people, uh,
as well as how that's impacting,
uh,
any kind of a competition and squashing
that competition from coming up and
saying, hey, you know, you've got Facebook
and then you've got this other new tech,
not social media technology.
They've got better privacy standards
and better service for the consumer than
Facebook. But anytime that that
tries to happen, uh, you know,
they're quickly squashed by companies
like Facebook or Google for that matter
are bought up. Exactly. Yeah.
That's the big concern.
So there's just not enough variety.
And there's also a big concern that I
have a big concern that there's a bunch of
people that don't seem to understand the
consequences of what they're calling d
platforming people,
which basically censoring
people did taking people out
of the public discussion.
And when you,
when you do that and you create a
bubble or you create a one party leaning
institution, one party leaning
conglomeration of human beings,
you're going to develop some real
anger on the other side. Yeah.
And it does the opposite
of what you wanted to do.
What you want to do is make
the world a better place.
Let's take some of these angry voices
out of the mix and let's make the world a
better place.
It just makes them more angry.
Then encourage,
encourage discourse.
Encourage these kinds of
conversations where you can,
you can engage with people who might have
a different view on an issue or might
have a different experience that they
bring to the conversation and to do so.
That actually helps increase the
knowledge and understanding that we have.
Yeah.
I think we have to reward
civil discourse as well.
I think we have to be kinder
to each other and we have to,
we have to be more upset at people that
are acting like shitheads online for no
reason. Like you're just, you think
that it's just online, but it,
what it is is communication and if
you're interested in shitty communication
online, you're just a shitty
communicator. Okay. All this column,
it being a troll and all
those different things,
all these different labels that people
put on to make it cuter and whitewash it.
It's not good. It's not
good for anybody. Yeah.
If people could figure out how to be
less angry and their online lives and wow
and communicate about issues,
I think we'd find that we meet more
in the middle than we think we do.
I think there's also a problem that
people have where they become married to
their ideas and they dig
their heels in and they,
they support their ideology and
the very rigid about it. Yeah.
And that is only strengthened when
you silence people. Yeah. It's,
it does the opposite of what
you're hoping it's going to do.
It makes the world a worse
place. It makes look, if people are
saying things that you don't like,
you don't have to read that.
But if you tell people that no one can
read that though, they're going to go,
why do you get to decide who are you?
Who are you?
You are a regular person.
How wiser you. Yeah.
How many steps ahead of you
played this game. That's right.
Cause I'm looking at this game.
I'm looking at civil war. Yeah.
I'm looking at worst case scenario.
This goes to that. That goes to this,
this guy attacks that. That guy
attacks this. They can't talk anymore.
You got people fight in the streets. That
happens. That's a human characteristic.
That's right. That's right. And that's,
that is where this path ends up.
This path that we're on of this,
this hyper partisanship,
this extreme divisiveness where it's
either you're in my tribe or you're in the
other tribe and the arrows are pointed
at each other without any willingness to,
once again,
just let's just have a conversation.
Let me hear where you're coming from here,
where I'm coming from.
We can disagree without
being disagreeable.
We can even have a heated
conversation and a debate.
And I would at the end of it,
you're saying is patriotic.
Yeah. This is patriotic.
And I think it's unpatriotic
to be partisan. Yeah.
Cause I think we're supposed
to be on a team together. Yeah.
This is supposed to be team America.
Exactly. What do we do? We're,
we're fighting over
nonsense and missile mis,
characterizing people's positions just to
suit our own ideas. That's right. It's,
it's foolish. It's foolish. And as
you said, it's extremely dangerous.
And the American people are the ones who,
who ultimately lose in all of this.
Uh,
this has been one of the most frustrating
things that I've seen and experienced
throughout my over six years in
Congress that really started,
um, like when I first went
up after I got elected, uh,
we're after every election happens
in new members of Congress.
They go and they have what's called new
member orientation and they give you
these books and here's the maps and
here's where your offices and you know,
all the, all the administrative and
logistical stuff. But very quickly,
I would say within the first
few days, um, you know,
where we first come in together
as Democrats and Republicans,
Immediately Kate Democrats go this way.
Republicans go this way,
immediately separated.
And what were told right off the bat is,
look, this is about, uh, getting
wins for our political party.
And if you work with the Republican,
then that's going to hurt the party.
Especially if you work with a Republican
and the Democratic Party is trying to
take out, forget the substance of the
idea, forget the substance of the bill.
And this happens on the opposite side
is while Republicans with Democrats,
both both political parties or dif or are,
I'm guilty of this,
where they're really putting the interest
of the political party ahead of the
people who just voted for
us to go and serve them.
And not just the Democrats who
voted for me, but yes, the,
the independence and the Republicans
both who voted for me or who didn't,
but who, uh, I serve as
part of my constituency.
And uh, you just, you continue to have
continued to see this where, you know,
you'll have a bill that, because
it's Democrat, Bill Republicans
vote against it.
Substance aside or Republican
Bill Democrats voted against
it just because it's
a republican bill. But then, hey,
if, if they come in and you know,
a month or a year later introduced
the same bill or a similar bill,
but now because it's a democratic
bill, okay everybody, hey, let's go,
let's go and support this legislation.
You can imagine why there is
so much gridlock in Washington,
why nothing really gets done.
And ultimately how this divisiveness in
this hyper partisanship is hurting the
ability for the needs of the
American people to be served.
When you talk about people at yourself
that are completely funded by the public
and you have this very logical and
objective way of discussing this gridlock,
do you think that the future is in young
people like yourself getting involved
in politics, that they, they're not
connected to this old world for 35,
45 years, this world? It sounds
like this is just what you do. Yeah.
I mean I watched house of cards.
I get kinda get it sort of what that,
that seems like chaos and it seems
like there's no way to fix that.
It's almost like these people
have to stop being politicians.
They have to be voted out
or die off when done well.
I think it's evident where we see
those who are very entrenched in this,
um,
this broken system feel very threatened
by the rise of people powered campaigns,
individual contributions coming in and
supplanting the big money that they get
from, um, you know, packs
and packs and lobbyists and,
and, and there's fear
there because they see, um,
their whole world being disrupted by
people like me or others who are coming in
and saying,
no,
we're not buying into any of that and
we're coming in to actually fulfill the
mission that we've been charged with
by those who voted for us to serve the
people, all the people of this country.
And would you say that, would you,
well this is my position.
I think that Trump plays a part of that
because I think he was the first guy to
camp the,
come to come in basically self funded or
being funded through his own means and
not listening to the rest of the
Republican Party saying, Hey,
I'm going to take over and
I'm going to do this my way.
And then knowing that he could do that
and knowing that there were so many
Republicans against him and knowing that
there's so many Democrats against him
as well, but yet he's still the
president. Yeah. People like Jesus,
this is a fragile system or the system is,
it's what they've done to acquire
power is still very vulnerable.
Even though they have this deeply
entrenched system of weird little
relationships that it's not good enough
that if the people do rise up and they
decide, hey, we want to
put Tulsi in as president,
you're going to have
a different situation.
A lot of you clowns going to
be out of work. Absolutely.
I mean, and that's really,
that's the message that we're carrying to,
to living rooms,
town halls and communities
across the country is,
uh,
Washington continues to underestimate
the power of the people.
And it's supposed to work
for you. Exactly. And that's
the thing is, you know,
our founding fathers had this vision for
our country that our government would
be of the people,
by the people and for the people.
And instead what we have is a government
of the rich and powerful by and for the
rich and powerful of the special
interests in corporations buy in for the
special interest in corporations and
you know, we, the people get left behind
and they continue to talk to us
like they're in control. Yeah.
They're one of us and they're
supposed to be public.
Employees are supposed to be servants.
That's right of the public.
They don't talk like that.
No.
They talk like people who
are in a position of power
and influence and it's not
healthy.
It's not a healthy perspective.
DEF,
it's evident of that huge disconnect
between the bubble that is Washington and
the reality of the lives that we live
every day. People all across this country.
That's always the case though.
When people get in control of things
though is metal, make it easier for them,
make it better for them. What can
I do to make this a little easier?
Is there another way?
How can I help myself here?
How can I make sure that when I get out
of office I can do these public speaking
tours and make a quarter
million dollars a pop. Yeah.
When I hear about the money those guys
make to just go and talk. Yeah. What?
Who is paying for that?
He was paying to listen to
Hillary Clinton getting out of it.
Why are you getting out of that?
Can I listen?
I would love to like
pretend to be a banker,
to put a lizard skin face mask on and go
sit with those bankers and listened to
one of those conversations that Hillary
Clinton got paid a quarter million
dollars to talk to. Yeah. Never released
the transcripts for what is that about?
Who is,
it's some weird sneaky deal that they
make where nobody wants to pay that like
go to that. A massive scar guards see
many tickets you sell. Right, exactly.
That their bill and Hillary are doing
like the speaking tour thing right now.
I am baffled as to who is going to pay
to go see bill and Hillary bullshit them.
They're doing it together now,
right? Yeah. Pell is so old.
Why didn't you just
come clean? You know, I,
I would love to get that guy and just
get them drunk and put them on the edge.
Just like have him just talk about life.
No, you only got like a few years left.
Everything's falling apart in your body.
What are your regrets?
What'd you do wrong?
What could you have done differently?
Stop all this bullshitting. Like
w you know, have him on your show.
I would love to,
I would love to do mushrooms with them.
That's what I wanted to have him on the
show and do it in Colorado because they
did some analyze mushrooms.
It's just this role of being the person
that is in control of this country is
always been this impossible task.
And when I see a person like you
who wants to do it, I say, listen,
you have some of the best ideas in the
most healthy perspective that I've ever
heard from anyone that's
ever running for president.
But why would you want
to do that to yourself?
Those are the two things that I
think go because it's not for myself
and, and it's not to be in control
of the country and the people.
It's to serve the people and our country.
It's a continuation of this mission
that I've chosen for my life to be of
service, to find different
ways to do that. You know,
it started in Hawaii with gathering my
friends as a kid and going in and picking
up trash off the beach on the weekends
and experiencing even then at a young age
that that made me happier
then than anything else.
Then,
you know,
going and playing video games
with my friends or anything
like that and that MMM.
That mission that that
was deeply ingrained in me
further with my service in the
military, serving as a
soldier where, you know,
I'm serving alongside people of all
walks of life as you know, every race,
religion, ethnicity,
orientation, everything,
every one of us wearing that same uniform,
serving that same flag that represents
the American people with that laser like
focus on putting service above self.
And that's what I seek to
bring to the White House. To,
to restore those values of integrity
and honor and respect to make it so that
that White House is a beacon of light
for the American people to know that that
White House belongs to them and represents
them and their interests and their
interests alone.
Does anybody, yeah. I mean, even a
person like you who's on the outside,
do you think anybody truly knows what
it's like to run the country until they
get in there? Do they, can
you even have an idea of what,
how impossible a task it
is to be in control of the
economy, the environment, the,
the infrastructure,
the military,
our position in the world to get
it seems like the most insane duty.
Yeah.
To require someone to run all those
things and be aware of all those things.
To be responsible for all of the
successes and all of the failures. Yeah.
MMM. It's an awesome responsibility.
There's no question about that. Uh,
and I think it fulfills
that, um, that hire,
that hire,
that higher calling that this is not
about any kind of selfish interest.
This for me is not about any
kind of ambition that I've had.
I've never had any kind of thought,
well, I want to be president one day,
or even I want to be a
member of Congress one day.
It's always been about how can I,
how can I best be of service and
how can I make a greater impact?
And that's what I've seen throughout my
time in Congress where I've served on
these committees.
I've served on the foreign affairs
in armed services committees.
I've been been calling for and fighting
for an end to these wasteful regime,
change wars and end to this new
cold war and nuclear arms race.
There's only so much I can do
as a member of Congress, uh,
to be able to serve as president
and commander in chief.
I know that I can make that kind of
impact and see change in our policy that
keeps our country safe,
that moves us closer to that
future of peace and prosperity.
And that's where I hope to
be able to make a difference
if you'd become pros, excuse me, when
you become pros, there you go. Sorry.
And
you do get to change the way we spend
money and stop spending money on these
regime change wars.
What would be the first thing you invested
in in this country and how would you
go about doing that
question? I think there's, um,
I'd want to give that some thought
because there are a whole host of,
of challenges that we're facing.
You know, I mean, healthcare is,
is among the top of the list.
And you know,
we've talked a little bit about
that the last time I was here.
Our crumbling infrastructure continues
to be something that's not only just
uncomfortable every time we're driving
over potholes, it's actually, uh,
threatening peoples lives.
And wellbeing's uh,
I was in Iowa a few weeks ago and we
visited this a few communities that were
completely inundated and
devastated by the flooding. Um,
that took place there. Gosh, about
three, three, four weeks ago now. Uh,
many of them have not been
able to return to their homes.
We went and helped out one family.
We were tearing down drywall and ripping
up the floors and underneath the wood
in the floors, there was still
like tons of water, uh, in place.
And they were talking about how even with,
you know,
the aid from FEMA and s
and SBA loans that they,
they are unwilling to put a single
dollar back into rebuilding their homes
because they're hearing
from the government and the
Army Corps of engineers that
it may take two to four years to fix the
levees that broke down and caused that
flooding.
So why would they go and try to pour
their life savings back into rebuilding
their homes when they could get flooded
again in a year or in two years?
Because we're not making the kinds of
investments in our infrastructure that we
need to make. Uh, so there's an education.
I mean, there's a whole host of issues,
um,
that I think we need to look at how we
can best provide the resources that are
necessary to improve those services,
uh, to the American people.
And also look at how,
how we're doing business and,
and fixing the problems that exist
within those different agencies.
There's always been a call to help
countries in need in the world.
There's always been a call for the
United States to step in and you know,
and and,
and do something.
But yet there's problems in this
country that are, that never change.
There's bad communities in this country
that are impoverished and crime ridden
that have been the same
way. Yeah. For decades,
there was a former Baltimore police
officer named Michael Wood who came on my
podcast and he was talking to me about
the time when he was in the Baltimore
Police Department.
They found a piece of paper that was
documenting various crimes from the 1970s
for someone,
one of the years from 1970 something and
it was the same exact crime in the same
exact area that they were having problems
with. Now, whether it's homicide,
narcotics,
whatever it was,
they were having the exact
same in the exact same places.
And then he realized like, well, this
is, there's no effort put to change this.
Yeah, there's no, it is, if you're talking
about decades and decades and decades,
why wasn't there a money
funneled into this community?
Why isn't there some community
centers that help children?
Why isn't there an emphasis
on Edrick better education?
Why isn't there more police officers or
at least some sort of civilian presence
that helps out people and stop some of
this crime and gives people a better
place to live and then fix a lot of this
what you're seeing decade after decade.
Yeah.
If we want to make America better,
the best way to do that is
to fix the weakest parts.
The weakest parts of the people
that are born in a shit situation,
they don't get a good break.
They got a bad break.
They're born and crime ridden environment,
and then they have to figure out how to
be a better person while dealing with
all this and then you've got people that
are aloof to this that are like, hey,
figure it out for yourself.
I did like as if we all start from the
same spot in this crazy game called life
because we don't know those
people are in the worst spot.
Why can't we fix the worst bot? It seems
like we could, if we can help Iraq,
if we can invade Syria,
if we can do some of the
things that people either
want us to do or we have done,
why can't we do that?
Exactly,
and that's, that's what I often
remind people is that right now,
today we spend $4 billion
every month in Afghanistan,
$4 billion every month,
every single month.
Imagine what could be done with those
dollars in those resources in communities
like Baltimore and communities like Flint,
Michigan,
where people are still being
poisoned by their water,
where they're being lied to and
cheated by their leadership.
Where the governor sent in
these inspectors and cleared
the water saying, hey,
everything's fine.
What he didn't tell people was
that when those inspectors went in,
they turn the faucet and let the water
run for five minutes before they tested
it to clean all the crap out of the pipes
and create this false conclusion that
somehow the water is cleaned.
When the people who live there know
that it is still not safe to drink.
And for some folks they can't even
take a shower in their own homes.
And so that's why you're not going to
hear any other presidential candidates
talking about the cost of war and where
our money is going and how it is counter
to our national security.
It's making us less safe.
It's counter to the interest of our
people and the people in those countries.
But this is why I talk about this
everywhere I go. Because it's central,
it's central to our ability to address
these domestic challenges that we are
facing.
We in this country are facing
in communities across the
country and dealing with
health care,
affordable housing.
There's a homeless crisis in both
urban cities and rural communities.
People who are not able to
afford to put a roof over there,
the people who are working full time,
maybe one,
maybe two jobs even still can't
afford to put a roof over their heads.
There are serious issues
that we need to address here,
but to think that somehow we'll have the
resources to do so without addressing
where trillions of our dollars have been
going now for the last several years,
uh, is a lie. It's just not true.
When you talk about people
that are working full time
jobs and they still don't
have enough money to get by,
what could you do to change that?
I think there's a, we, there's not
one single action that can fix that.
Uh, you know, I'm pushing
for a living wage.
I think it's important
that that should be, uh,
it's going to be different in
different places. You know, I've,
I'm a cosponsor of the,
uh,
congressional legislation to raise the
minimum wage to $15 at the federal level.
Um,
you know,
there has not been an increase in the
federal minimum wage for a very long time.
Uh, and I think that's, that's a
step that can be taken. But you know,
Los Angeles is like Hawaii where a $15
an hour job is not going to be enough to
pay the rent because you've
got high cost of living.
So living wage is going to be higher and
in communities like ours than it is in
smaller communities or
communities in the Midwest.
What would you suggest for Los
Angeles? $20 an hour? I don't,
I don't know what the answer is here.
It would have to be more,
I think so the argument against that
would be that small businesses would go
under or hire less people.
Were that somehow or another
it would be bad for business.
What is there? I think
there's a, uh, you know,
I mean the cost of living here is higher.
And so what we are paying the
employees who work in these industries,
in these service jobs,
it has to match that.
It has to correlate with
that higher cost of living.
It costs more to go out to eat here
than it does to go out to eat in a
restaurant in, I don't
know, Alabama for example.
So I think we've got to,
we've got to recognize people
who are doing the work, um,
that correlates with the higher cost of
living that we're seeing already. Um,
I'm, I'm really looking at the
universal basic income, uh,
and seeing how that could be a tool to,
um,
help deal with a lot of these poverty
stricken communities and people who've
been struggling and still unable to
dig themselves out of a hole there and
seeing how that potentially could
replace a lot of the bureaucracy,
a lot of the money that we're spending
on bureaucracy and a lot of social
welfare programs perhaps to both save
money and to provide support directly,
uh, to people who need it. Uh,
so I think that's an option that
we've got to consider this. It's,
it's not simple.
And so I'm doing the research and figuring
out how exactly that would work and
how exactly we'd pay for it. Uh, but we
also have to look at affordable housing.
I think not accepting the fact that
the high cost of housing is what it is,
um, is, is not the solution. MMM.
There's a lot of money that goes into
our housing and urban development
department,
but is it really having the effect that
we needed to have to make it so that you
know, whether it's cops are
teachers, are firefighters,
people who are working in these public
service jobs are able to afford to live,
live in the communities where they're
working. Now, we were in Malibu yesterday.
We had a town hall there yesterday
and took a tour with the mayor,
city council members,
community leaders around a lot of the
areas that were completely devastated by
the fires. And that was one of the
things that they mentioned is that a,
they pointed out a trailer park.
Um,
traditionally where a lot of
those first responders live,
that's where the workforce in Malibu
have lived in that trailer park.
And they said that it's not unheard of.
That one of those trailer
homes go for 1 million bucks,
1 million bucks,
and you don't even get to own the
land that your trailer sits on.
And so this is a real problem that they're
facing is people who are teaching in
that area at the firefighters
who are working in that area.
They're not able to afford to live
in the community that they serve.
But how could that be fixed?
That's a supply and demand thing.
There's some communities,
I mean, you know, there's,
there's land in the valleys and,
and other areas,
but some communities are dealing with
this, both in the private sector. There's,
there's hotels in Hawaii for example,
who are recognizing that they can't
attract workers to work in the hotels
because they can't afford to
live near where they work.
And they're starting to buy up properties
to actually provide that workforce
housing at an affordable cost to be
able to attract those workers. Uh,
some communities are doing the same
thing for, uh, for first responders,
for firefighters and others. So this is
a problem that, that a lot of, you know,
city councils and local communities
are trying to deal with and solve.
But I think it also points to a bigger
problem that we have a nationally that
there is just not enough affordable,
truly affordable housing for
working people in the country.
But a place like Malibu is always been
this exclusive community because there's
just not that much Malibu. It's next to
the water. So it's more valuable. Yeah.
Like if,
if is there a way to do
anything that would change that?
Well, this, that's what I was asking
the mayor about and that, and that was,
that was one of the things they
said that has been, um, you know,
people look at Malibu and they're like,
well,
that's where a bunch of multimillionaire
rich people go and buy their beach
homes. But there has always
been, uh, you know, the,
the basis of that community was really
founded on those who worked to build the
community. Uh, you know,
middle, middle class,
middle class people who are
increasingly being pushed out.
If you're not living in the home
that, you know, your grandfather,
your great grandfather built,
then you're not going to be able to afford
to stay there. Uh, so, you know, he,
we didn't get into the,
the details on what they're looking at,
but this is something that
the city council and the
mayor are grappling with now
to be able to attract workers
who want to work in the area,
but who don't want to have to drive
two hours or three hours just to get to
their place of work. Yeah. I just don't
know how you would ever do that. Yeah.
Especially with all those fat cats that
are living in Malibu. It's a crazy place.
Live.
Yeah.
Those houses on the beach or like
ridiculously expensive. Yeah.
And that's where a lot of,
I mean a lot of the folks you were talking
to yesterday, they live, uh, you know,
up on the mountain or in the valley or
that's a better spot anywhere. The thing,
the thing about being by the beaches,
people could just kind of hang out
in your backyard, like right there,
like right where your bedroom is.
It can be people that are cooking out
four feet away from your head. Yeah.
That's not so much privacy.
You've got none. It's the
beach. It's everybody's. Yeah.
Like people have tried to kick people off
it too, which gets really strange. Yeah.
There's been a lot of those cases
where they hire private security,
but it's like trying to kick someone out
of a park because you decided to have a
picnic. That's true, man.
This beach is everybody.
That's the ocean to stay that way.
Yeah. It has to stay that way. That way.
I have a problem with,
this is a personal problem with,
with municipalities that charge
you to go to the beach. Crazy.
So if I have no money in my pocket,
you're going to bar me from going and
putting my feet on the sand and go for a
surf in the ocean. It's insane.
It's insane. It is wrong. Right?
I mean,
I could see if you had a donation box
to help people clean up the beach.
That's all I could see.
Donations. Yep. That's all.
Throw some money in and be like,
yeah, I'll pay for my
parking. Sure, sure. You know,
but don't stop me from
coming on the beach. Like,
I'll catch a bus if I don't have any
money, I'll get you us to the beach.
Poor People's,
you've got to like,
that's the whole reason we have these
national parks, national wilderness areas.
It's anybody. Yeah. Anybody
can get in there. Yeah.
That's the beautiful thing about,
one of the best things about the,
the system that we have in
place in America is that
there's so much public land
and people don't understand that they've
never been to other countries where
that's just not the case. Everything
is private in many, many countries.
You can't just go camping. You can't
just take a raft and go down the river.
You can't just do that. And what
happens when those public spaces are,
are lost,
they're lost,
they're lost forever and you pave
over them when you develop them.
You know when your beaches become trash
with pollution and others like that's a
treasure. It's a treasure
that's lost. Well,
we have our forefathers to
thank for their foresight.
Like Theodore Roosevelt
saw this in advance and met
with great resistance from a
lot of big businesses that just wanted
to put apartments up everywhere and start
building factories.
Yeah.
And we created this incredible system
of public land in this country that's
unprecedented. Yeah. Yeah. I
mean, only Canada has something
that rivals us. Oh Man.
I guess Australia's got a lot of
public land too, but it's just,
there's other countries that have it,
but it's amazing what we have here.
And in terms of our diversity of,
of scenery and,
and where you could go to,
I mean,
you could go to the desert or you
could go to Idaho and you know,
go to quarterly volcano in Hawaii. Yeah.
Well I think you guys have an advantage.
I really do.
And I've said this about many people
that are faced with incomparable beauty
and this
in arguable sense of your perspective.
And I think if you're living on a
volcano in the middle of the ocean,
you're five hours by plane from anywhere.
Like you guys have a different vibe,
you know? And I think, yeah, you know,
I mean you go to, you, you,
you turn on the news or you talk to
politicians in Washington. I by okay,
we've got to protect our environment and
it's becomes like a political talking
point.
But a,
I'm so grateful to have grown
up in Hawaii and uh, you know,
that talking point is
actually a way of life.
Like this connection that we
have, uh, you know, with nature,
with mother earth is something that's
real and it's cultural and it's passed
down from generations and it's,
it's actually living out,
uh, that, that saying
that Mahatma Gandhi had,
that the earth provides
enough for everyone's need
but not everyone's greed and
what a powerful thing that is.
And we think about both how we live our
lives personally in being respectful and
being thoughtful about our impact
on other people and on our planet.
And then of course for policy makers
who are making those decisions about how
our natural resources are used,
stopping them from being
exploited or polluted or lost for,
you know,
short term monetary profits or gains.
There's a certain thing that
happens in Hawaii as well,
where people are more accountable
because you can't get away from anybody.
That's right.
Somebody's uncle or Auntie is going
to see and be like, hey, junior,
what's going on? You're on
an island. You gotta be nice.
I can't drive like a dick. Yeah.
I worked for a senator Akaka,
who's a US senator from Hawaii
for many decades in Washington,
and I worked for him in Washington for
two years between my two deployments. Uh,
but he was a guy who
embodied that Aloha spirit.
Uh, his wife, um, who we call
auntie Millie. She, she's,
she's got a, she's a firecracker. She's a
little feisty, but even she, she's like a,
you don't talks. Think about anybody
in Hawaii because you never know.
You might be related to them,
but you know,
it's good words to live by, whether
you're related or not. Just, Hey,
don't talk stink. Don't talk trash about
somebody. Show respect. Share that Aloha.
Even if even if you're different, even if
you disagree, show that respect. That's,
that's what my boss did. That's the
senator Akaka did. And, and you know,
he passed away a couple of years ago,
but people in Washington still
remember and talk about him,
Democrats and Republicans. Uh, it's just
the kindest human beings I've ever known.
The problem with people
is talking stink is fun,
especially when there's nobody around.
It's like a national pastime in many ways.
The spreading of bad vibes is discouraged
in an area where you kind of have to
know most of the people
around. Yeah. Yeah.
Which I want to give a shout out to one
of the guys I met yesterday in Malibu
Guide named Keegan. Uh, he
organized like, I dunno,
20 or 25 of his friends and they went
and they just started like fighting fires
and people's houses all on their own
organized like aid stations and food
stations, getting generators.
And they did incredible work. Uh,
but I told them I was coming on
your show today and he was, um,
he just said that,
that Joe Rogan and his show has made
such a deep impact on my life because he
went from somebody who was
really triggered was the
word he used by people who
were saying things that he disagreed with.
And you inspired him to kind of open
his mind and his eyes and to recognize,
um, that we are stronger and we are better
when we have this kind of respectful
discourse.
And we're open to hearing from an,
I'm trying to understand people who may
have a different view rather than being
triggered and running away in the opposite
direction or reacting in a negative
way. So I just wanted to
pass that on because, um,
you made a big impact on him and on a
lot of a lot of his friends and a lot of
people in the country and that that's
having a positive impact on, um,
you know,
our culture. Well that's
very nice. And shout out to
Keegan. I appreciate that. Um,
I think that's something we can all learn
how to do. And I learned how to do it.
Yeah.
It's not something I was naturally yeah.
But I didn't naturally gravitate towards
having good conversations with people.
Yeah. It was a dickhead when I was
young. I was fighting all the time. Yeah.
Most of what I did was involved with,
I was involved in martial arts,
so it was always involved with competition
was always very intense and I was
very competitive and I wasn't necessarily
that Nice, you know, all the time. And,
um,
when I examine my life over
time I realized that hmm.
The things that always felt the worst
or conflicts that were unnecessary.
And in particular the things that I
judged myself the most harshly where at my
mistakes or failures in my
attempts at doing things,
it was my misbehaving, my, my, um,
just being a jerk where it
wasn't necessary or having
an opportunity to be nice
and not taking it or escalating things
where I could have used diplomacy. Right.
And I just learned over time that a lot
of it is the way I was communicating
with people where I was failing was
how I was approaching their thoughts.
And that I was immediately trying to be
right rather than listen to them and I
was thinking about them differently.
Then I think about myself.
One of the things that happened to me
when I had children was I started thinking
of people like babies that grew up.
I think of everyone like old people.
Like it freaks me out when I go to
the, uh, I was in a casino yesterday.
I was passing by this old lady
smoking cigarettes, playing Bingo,
playing roulette, rather
slots, whatever. Fuck it is.
Whenever wasted money and I'm watching
her do this and I'm like, Oh God, this is,
it was a baby. That was, someone's paid
me. Now here it is barely hanging on.
Who the fuck knows, right? Yeah.
That's what she likes to do.
Maybe I'm just an idiot,
but my,
my perspective has radically shifted and
as I've gotten older and then started
this podcast,
that thing that I realized was that I
needed to get better at talking to people
when I was doing the podcast.
I need to get better at listening
and then I needed to have less bias.
Perspectives may be less biased points
of view and just try to understand what
someone's saying and if I disagree,
disagree and try to be as nice as possible
while also being accurate about how
much something bothers me. Yeah.
But being nice like we can do that.
We can all be better off that way.
You know,
and I share a lot of black
men when you get to these,
like if you want to look
at the left or the right,
I share so much in common with so many
people in both the left and the right
that I almost want to put
a graph down of like what?
How do you live your life like a unites
to people are ya, are you friendly?
Do you have good friends he care about?
Do you have buddies that could call
you at four o'clock in the morning?
Say you've got to drive two hours and
pick me up and he would immediately do it.
Yeah. Like what? What do you like? Okay.
Then what's bothering you?
What's bothering you in the news,
what's bothering you and why do these
things exist and how many of them are
bullshit. Yeah, and for me
it was like there was a lot
of them that were bullshit.
I was like,
what am I wasting time and effort and
thinking about what do I care what people
do? I don't, I don't care. I want you to
be nice and that's it. And then it get,
it gets down to political and social
issues and it gets down to the heavy ones.
Things like abortion and war and you know,
freedom of religion.
And then in these,
these things I think are the ones where
we should all just be communicating as
commonly in, as in as objectively as
possible. And we should discourage this,
this tribal perspective discouraged this
idea of being married to your own ideas
and, and trying to win these
arguments which you see in Congress,
which you see in political campaigns,
which you see in television.
News is a fucking dumpster fire.
Every single time they have the panel
with the three people is just by,
I can watch it. It's nonsense. Thank
you for your time. What did you, what,
what waste is this?
It's just people shouting over people.
You never find out what the fuck anybody
really believes. You just hear their,
their, their talking points
blurted and vomited out.
And this is the news. What's actually
happening is completely lost and it's so,
it's,
it's so limited and this is how a lot
of us are getting our view of the world.
Yeah.
And I feel like
things are changing.
I think the world is a different place
than it was even just 10 years ago,
I think.
I think so too.
I think humans are different and I think
we just were not aware of how much all
of this conversation on,
on all of our analyzing the world around
us has shifted over the last decade or
so.
Yeah. People are looking, I feel
like people are looking for, uh,
for the facts.
They're looking for more information.
They're less likely to just accept at
face value what they're seeing on TV or
what they're hearing. Uh, which I think
is, is a positive thing. Uh, and I think,
I think we do need to look at the
leadership of this country to, um,
to set this culture for a civil discourse,
for making it,
making it okay and encouraging
actually those kinds of conversations.
And that's where if you look at it,
you've watch cspan one night
when he can't fall asleep. Uh,
you'll see in the floor of Congress,
you've got the Democrats who
were all sitting on one side.
You've got the Republicans
all sitting on the other side.
And unfortunately,
not often enough do you see intermingling
and conversation and people go into
the other side of the island actually
getting, getting to know people. Um,
that was something that when I
first got elected, I was told, look,
as a new member of Congress, serving in
the minority with Republicans in charge,
coming from a small state like Hawaii,
you will never get anything done.
So just accept it.
Just accept that reality that you're
not going to get anything done,
wait several years or whatever. But
one of the first things that I did was,
uh, I got to get to know people.
I got to make friends. So I, uh,
my, my mom and dad, they're small
business owners and they had this, uh,
Macadamia nut toffee business. And
so I called home and I said, hey mom,
can you make 434 boxes of your toffee
for every single member of Congress,
all the Democrats, all the
Republicans. She's like, wow,
that's a great idea. Yeah,
sure, I'd be happy to. And then I said,
Oh, I've got one more, one more request.
Can you make a bigger box?
Uh,
435 bigger boxes of toffee for the staff
of every member of Congress because
they're the ones who make shit
happen. And she said, okay,
I'm going to take me a little bit longer.
But, uh, yes, I think that's a great idea.
So, you know, I started
writing handwritten notes to
every one of my colleagues,
introducing myself.
And as we started delivering these
little gifts of Aloha to their offices,
it was amazing how quickly I saw while
on the House floor casting votes,
I have Republican chairman of powerful
committees making their way across from
the republican side to the democratic
side. Uh, saying thank you so much.
I really appreciate it.
It was delicious.
I need to get more from
you cause I ate it all.
I got to take some home to my wife
or my husband and then saying,
tell me what's going on in Hawaii.
Tell me what your constituents
are worried about.
I am the chairman of the
Transportation Committee,
the Agriculture Committee
or whatever it is.
Let me know how we can work together.
Just that one small outreach of Aloha,
open the doors to these relationships
that enabled me to be able to pass my
first piece of legislation like my first
six months as a member of Congress from
a small state in the
minority, um, as a democrat.
And it's because just
treating people with respect,
treating people with Aloha and saying,
yeah,
we can disagree even on nine out of 10
things, but on that 10th thing like,
Hey, let's talk. Let's get something done.
Was that eye opening for you and when
did you at that moment in time realized
like, Hey, I not only can
I make an impact here,
I can do this the way I want to do it?
Yes,
I can be a kind person and
reach out and do you mean,
and I don't have to listen to these
people that are entrenched? Exactly.
It,
it,
it directly disproved what we were told
in those first days as new members of
Congress in Washington. And a
further affirmed what I already knew,
both from what I learned
from Senator Akaka,
what I knew from growing up in Hawaii
with the Aloha spirit, that this,
this ability to transcend all of
this superficial divisiveness,
uh, whether it be based
on politics like you said,
or religion or race or ethnicity or,
or any of these other things is what
has the power to bring us together as a
country.
Okay. That's a beautiful thing
to hear. Like that's true.
That's what people want to hear. They
want to hear someone who thinks that way.
Yeah and that like, oh, we're
okay. We're going to be okay.
Like we can move forward and be okay and
do this like like human beings not like
politicians. Yeah, exactly.
There's a politician way of talking
and I want you to avoid at all costs.
I want you to never do this thing
with your thumb. Don't do that.
Because I was talking to someone and
they did that thing with their thumb.
I'd be like, hey bro, what the fuck's
wrong with your hand if you're not,
you didn't just have a stroke.
What's your Goddamn hand down?
I never realized it until I
started watching like myself.
Give speeches on TV that I do talk
a lot with my hands. That's fine,
but just don't do that. This one? Yeah.
This is just as offensive as if you
just started putting up your dukes,
like if you started like where we're going
to go out there and like what are you
doing man? He fighting people. Exactly.
Talking down like this is a
teacher move. Right, right.
I feel like this is a teacher
move it in the military,
they call it the knife hand. You see
like the drill instructors are like,
come on private. Yeah, but at least
gets a drill instructor. Exactly.
You're supposed to listen to,
this is the fucking public servant.
He was like at a half a fist.
Like there's no reason to ever put your
hand like that. This is not a good move.
Like unless you're trying to poke somebody
in the eye to see only reason why you
should have your thumb up like that.
Even know where that comes from.
Clinton Move Clinton I think was the
first guy to do it. That was his shit.
He used to do that. Funny. We're going
to do here. He used to have this thing.
He would do it. His thumb. Yeah.
Would drive me crazy. I'd be like,
this is such a bizarre thing. He
doesn't want to be forceful. Yeah.
He doesn't want to have a fist and he
doesn't want to do and so just stick one
finger out and that that,
that deescalates who was making fun
of that Bedo Guy. What's his name?
Yeah, he, his hand movements. You've
got some wacky hand stuff that he does.
You can't be named Baido I'm sorry.
It's too close to Beta.
Just everyone should have told him that
one value away from being like the most
mocked thing in society when it
comes to males. Can't do that.
I don't even know if he's a good
guy or not, but you can't do that.
You got to get in something. He's a
friend of mine changed name Homie. Yeah,
it's too late.
You've got to get plastic surgery.
Come back with a different social security
number. It's just too close. Yeah,
and don't be skateboarding. No,
no. What's wrong? Let's keep going.
Know what you're knowing it.
Does he know what he's doing or was
he just goofing around? Young dude,
he probably knows what he's doing.
Doesn't look like it looks sloppy.
I didn't see it was pretty sloppy,
but it's a thing that people do with,
like I'm one of you how come on, I'm
letting you guys come on. It's like,
get out of here with that William. Yeah,
this is, I, I dunno sometimes like,
you know, I'll post
little, little videos, um,
that Abraham takes his Gopro of us out
surfing. And sometimes I get that fruit,
but like, oh, like why are you trying
to pretend something? I'm like, dude,
I just love the ocean. I Love Surfing.
I want to share this with everybody.
Yeah. It's, it's a simple thing.
People are funny like that.
They don't want you to be fake, so, but
they also don't want you to be real. Ooh,
that's true too. Right? Yeah, that's
true. Yeah. So it's, it's, I don't know,
it's some kind of in between or
something. I don't know. Well,
I think there's just certain
people that are malcontents. Yeah.
And you're not gonna,
you know,
if you addressed all the people
that are upsetting you all the time,
you would never get
anything done. Right? Yeah.
How are you recognize in that
though? Cause you're, how
old are you? 38. You're not?
No. You're very young in terms of like
someone who's going to be president.
Yeah. That's young. Thirties.
Um, I'll, I'll be, I'll just
say you're not that young.
I'm not that. Yeah. 38 for
presidents. That's young shell.
How old was JFK when he got elected?
I think like 41 42 older than he is.
I'm like that. Barely. I'll, I'll
do like, I'll be 41. I'm sworn,
sworn in as president. Right, right
around there. Okay. But like I say when,
but yeah, exactly. Confidence. Um, look,
look at, look at Donald Trump though.
So what? He's in his mid seventies. Right.
But his maturity is of an adolescent.
He's a Canadian test. He's of a
fitbit. He should have been a comedian.
I'm telling you,
the guy would've been killing it.
That's comic instead of a real
estate developer. Great timing. Yeah,
that's true. Yeah. He's
very mature. But my point is
maturity. Maturity Matters. Yes.
Experience matters.
And that the experience that I bring is,
is different from any other candidate
who's running for president of serving as
a soldier for 16 years of serving in
Congress on these, on these committees of,
of importance and national
security. Uh, you know,
I've started this state
legislature and the city council
and um, look, when you look back, we
talked about our founding fathers. Yeah.
Most of them who crafted the constitution
and who wrote the declaration of
independence or under the age of 40
many under the age of lived there,
40 bag men still still we're talking
about experience and maturity here.
I know you're, you're, no, you're
defending yourself. I fully support you.
I think you could be president 38. I
really do. I don't think it's a problem.
And at 40 for sure you'll be 24
years older or 24 months older,
you're going to be wiser.
You'll, you'll have it nailed.
But we do wonder, right? Like how,
when has a person had enough life
experience and what, but then again,
the question is what is that life
experience? Is it life experience?
Like you said, that leads you to
be an immature 17 year old, right?
Or is this the life experience of someone
who's served in combat and has Ben on
in Congress for six years and someone
who understands how the government works
and has a better
perspective of human beings?
Yeah,
it is.
It is that experience and it's what you
draw from it and the conclusions and the
judgment and the kind of leadership
that you would exercise. Yeah. You know,
there were a lot of folks in 2016
who said Hillary Clinton was the most
experienced candidate ever to run for
president because of the jobs she had held
or the experience that she had had.
Okay.
My problem was with her judgment and the
kinds of decisions that she would make
as commander in chief decisions
that would continue to send, uh,
people like me and my brothers and
sisters in uniform to continue to fight in
these wasteful regime change wars that
actually dishonor the oath that we all
take when we volunteer to serve,
to serve,
to protect and defend our
country and the American people.
And instead sending us on
these missions that, uh,
our counter to that promise that
undermine our national security,
that undermine the great sacrifice that
our troops and their families make.
So it's that judgment. It's the
experience and the judgment that, uh,
I believe we need to look for
in the next commander in chief.
It's what I bring to the table and
it's what I challenge voters too.
Ask the other candidates and to, to hold
them to account on both of those fronts.
Would they be ready to walk into that
Oval Office on day one and to serve our
country as commander in chief?
One of the messages that Trump was very
successful in getting out was that he
wanted to drain the swamp.
That we all realize that there's
just this tangled web of bureaucracy.
Yeah.
And
that
he did a good job of connecting
Hillary too, that bureaucracy and say,
this woman is just completely
entrenched in this world.
She's never going to get out.
She's not even a real person anymore.
She's just a professional politician.
And he would highlight all the different
things that she did and lied and all
call her crooked Hillary and that
just got stuck. What made him,
one of the things that
made him very attractive to
people is that he seemed like
a person didn't seem like a
politician that seem like a person.
How do you avoid communicating like a
politician when you're doing this in mass,
when you're communicating with
giant groups of people, when you're,
you're having these big
speeches in these big places,
how do you do it without being,
how do you do it and still let
people know you're just a person?
Cause that's I think what
people are longing for and
what they don't see in many
candidates. You see this act like,
oh he's pretty good at it. Exact,
but I see the act. Yeah. I
don't see a person. Yeah.
Being myself speaking the truth and
standing up for what I believe in and why
I'm offering to serve our country,
think there's no really,
there's no other way to do it
because if I start like, okay,
how am I going to convey myself as a real
person? The only way to do that is to,
to actually be a real person and who
speaking truthfully and honestly and
respecting the American people and the
responsibility that I'm asking them to
bestow upon me. That mission that
I'm asking them to charge me with.
Yeah. Does this, you, you,
you've said you've always
been drawn to service. Yeah.
Does this seem like, uh, calling to you?
Like what does this feel like to you?
This idea that you are going
to be the commander in chief,
the greatest army the
world has ever known,
the leader of the free world in
a sense. Yeah. What does that,
what does that seem like to you?
The, the, the grave responsibility
that that job carries, uh,
and the seriousness with
which I would bring, uh,
my experience in my judgment
to fulfilling that job. MMM.
You know,
this is,
I think one of the problems that we
have too often in our politics is that
people self serving politicians are more
interested in keeping their job or in
getting the next job or you
know, in lining their pockets,
getting ready for the,
you know,
the afterlife or whatever.
When they leave their political
office that that somehow is, is,
is defining of who they are
rather than recognizing,
um,
that,
that to be able to serve the people
is a great honor and it's tremendous
responsibility and that's how I
approach serving in, uh, you know,
the local, the state level
and at Congress. Uh, and,
and how I approach being able to serve
the American people as president and
commander in chief.
It is a grave responsibility and I will
never forget for a single moment who I
serve and who I work for.
Okay.
What is your take on
wikileaks and Julian Assange?
Okay.
What happened with the,
with his arrest and all this
stuff that just went down, um,
I think poses a great threat to our
freedom of the press and to our freedom of
speech.
Yeah.
We look at what happened under
the previous administration
under Obama. You know,
they were trying to find ways to go
after a [inaudible] and wikileaks.
But ultimately they chose not to seek
to extradite him or charge him because
they recognized what a slippery slope
that begins when you have a government in
a position to,
uh,
Levy criminal charges and consequences
against someone who's publishing
information or saying things that the
government doesn't want you to say.
The government does him
sharing information the
government government doesn't
want you to share. And so the fact that
the Trump administration has chosen,
um,
to ignore that fact,
to ignore how important it is
that we uphold our freedoms,
freedom of the press and freedom
of speech and go after him.
It has a very chilling effect on
both journalists and publishers.
And you can look to both those
in the traditional media,
but also those in new media, uh, and
also on, on every one of us as American.
It was, it was, uh, uh, kind
of a warning call saying,
look what happened to this guy.
It could happen to,
you could happen to any one of us.
Well,
it's very transparent too,
cause there's no real compelling crime
for them to be going after him the way
they are. There's not one
thing that stands out in the,
the latest one is hacking and some
not even hacking it's
conspiracy conspiracy charges.
That doesn't make any sense that they
would spend that much time going after
that guy for those charges.
Yeah,
it's obvious and very transparent
that there's another ulterior motive.
Ulterior motive is that he leaked a bunch
of things that were incredibly, yes.
Embarrassing. That's right. And not only
that, but I think it was Secretary Palm,
Peo,
secretary of state who said that they
wanted to designate Wiki leaks and
assigned as a foreign intelligence agency.
So once you do that, then you're talking
about a whole different category.
So they're pushing out information once
again that the government didn't want
pushed out. [inaudible] if
the government then says, oh,
well now we're going to reclassify
you as a foreign intelligence agency,
then there's a whole different set of
rules of engagement that apply there.
Then you're no longer
protected under, uh, you know,
the freedoms that we hold dear.
The freedom of the press.
It's just such a disgusting
way of framing things. Like,
do you know he's on a foreign
intelligence agent? Yeah.
He's a guy that got information and
released it to the general public that the
government wanted to keep private.
It's really that simple. Yeah. Um,
Edward Snowden.
Yup. What is your similar, similar
situation? Similar situation?
I don't think I'm, I
don't think we, you know,
I remembered the very day
that I woke up, uh, in DC,
looked at my phone and started looking
through the headlines and saw those
headlines about how the NSA was mass
surveilling all of us and collecting our
phone records, collecting our phone
records and Verizon at t and t, t mobile.
And I was, I was shocked. So that
was something that Snowden uncovered,
uh, and released, uh,
something that I don't know that even as
members of Congress who would have been
aware of. So now that we
were aware of it than, hey,
we can take action two to f,
close those loopholes to change those
policies, to protect our civil liberties,
to protect our fourth amendment,
constitutional rights as Americans.
But was the NSA going to disclose that
information voluntarily on their own?
Absolutely not.
No idea, no. We would have had suspicions,
but then again we'd have tin foil hats
on and there was a gentleman who was,
who left the NSA very early on a hill was,
that was his last name, but he was
one of the first ones to discuss this.
This is post nine 11 when
they first started doing it,
but Snowden was the guy that really made
it abundantly clear to everybody that
not only are they doing that,
but they're also lying about it.
And even Obama was talking about we're
just collecting better data. The metadata,
like, no, you're not reading messages.
You could do anything. Exactly.
And this is just not an accurate
assessment of what was going on. No,
and it was outrageous.
And you had a,
I think he was the director
of the Department of
national intelligence at that
time.
James Clapper,
who sat before a committee in the
United States Senate and latently lied.
Yeah. He was asked very directly, are you
collecting this information? And he said,
no. Are you collecting this information
on American citizens? And he said, no.
And yet he's somebody who you see on TV
almost every day as an expert in this
country without any consequence
lying to the American people.
And I think that if you
polled the American people
and you ask us to vote on it,
know I w I think it would be a gigantic
landslide victory for Edward Snowden to
be exonerated and brought back to the
United States. They've got this guy, Lou,
he's in Russia now hiding.
Yeah.
Like it's crazy that he lives
over there and he can't leave.
And if he does come over here, they're
going to immediately gonna lock him up.
Yeah.
What would you do as president?
One thing that I think,
I want to answer your question,
but one thing that I think,
um, speaks to the Deign,
the dangerous nature of this culture
that we're living in now. Uh,
uh, the Senate minority leader, Chuck
Schumer had done an interview on,
I don't know, one of the major
networks, and I think he was,
I think he was talking about
Trump when he said, be careful.
You don't want a challenge,
the intelligence agencies
basically putting out that threat.
I don't know if,
if you can pull that exact quote up,
but I was shocked when I heard him say
that because it basically makes out that
these intelligence agencies are their
own separate branch of government.
And that if any one of us as Americans
or elected leaders in this country dares
to challenge or exercise
oversight over them,
then we will suffer the consequences.
Uh,
so as president would change
that culture of leadership,
that that leadership starts at the top.
And when you have people in positions of
leadership who continued to perpetuate
that culture of unaccountability,
of complete disrespect and
disregard for the constitution of,
of not understanding that yes,
we need to keep our country safe,
we also need to protect
our constitutional rights.
This is not a choice between the two,
which is so often how it's framed. Well,
if you want to protect
us against terrorists,
you've got to give up all of your rights
as Americans in your civil liberties
and your privacy's and, and just let
these intelligence agencies run, uh,
run free and run roughshod over us.
Uh,
and so that's the kind of of change
in leadership that I'll bring.
There's a whole host of policies that,
that we can look at. Uh, for example,
with the Patriot Act,
the Patriot Act is up for
reauthorization in Congress this year.
There have been different sections of
it that we have worked to try to change
and reform to make it so that agencies
like the NSA cannot collect our private
information as Americans
without a warrant.
But there is far more that has to be done,
uh,
to undo the damage that,
that we've already seen,
the abuse of our, of our rights and
privacies that we've already seen. Okay.
Yeah. Did you ever listen to the
Kennedy speech about secret societies?
[inaudible] Kennedy had
a, a fantastic speech, uh,
before he was assassinated where he was
discussing this very thing. And, uh,
he apparently,
uh,
had notions of disbanding the CIA and,
um,
he was very concerned with the power of
people like a j Edgar Hoover course and
yeah. That this was all
happening while he was president.
And he felt like there were people that
were involved in these secret societies
and these secrets meetings and that there
was a lot of conspiracy going on and
he thought that the very idea was
repugnant. It's a fantastic speech.
Interesting president. And the press
is what it's like, it's got a title,
it's a fantastic speech.
I'll check it out. Um,
but this has always been
the real concern that, uh,
people have that when you give someone
the ability to surveil the general
population,
when you give them,
they're going to use some
of that information to aid
in their allies and to work
against their enemies.
Yeah. That is ims a valid concern. Yes.
And I mean, this is what unfortunately,
we've already seen.
This is what has been revealed by some
of that information that was released by
Snowden and how,
for example,
the Pfizer court as we have it now
is a secret court that has and,
um,
has been abused for that purpose,
allowing for that surveillance
of Americans violating
our civil liberties and
privacies. And that's something
that we've got to fix that whole,
that whole Fi's a court from top to bottom
and how the different judges explain
pointed to people. It's, it's
basically, it's a, it's a,
a secret court that was
appointed, uh, I believe, uh,
created back in the 70s with the initial
objective of providing oversight over
the executive branch,
um,
mass surveillance that was happening at
that time or illegal surveillance that
was happening at that time,
unfortunately,
especially since nine 11.
Now you have this Pfizer court
that is both used to, uh,
approve surveillance and surveillance
programs on a foreign targets,
uh, but also on Americans as well. Uh,
the one of the many problems with this
is it's a secret court where you have a
judge and you have someone
representing the government,
whether it be one of the Intel agencies
or the dod or whatever coming before
this court in making their case to try to
get this warrant approved by the judge.
There is no advocate there for the people.
There is no civil liberties or
privacy advocate there. Uh, it's,
it's a one sided conversation.
Uh,
and the information being provided by
the government is the only information
that's being given to the
judge. Uh, so this is one of
the big problems there. And,
and we've seen over decades now
and especially since after nine 11,
that there have been
very, very, very few, um,
applications for these surveillance
warrants that have been rejected by the
judges. So, you know,
a rubber stamping of these
applications for warrants is,
is really what appears to
be happening. Um, you know,
there's a few different ways that
we're looking at trying to fix this.
There are some who are arguing, uh, to,
to take away the Pfizer court completely.
One of the concerns about
that is that if we do that,
then there has to be some other entity
in place to exercise oversight over the
executive branch and not allow them to,
um,
conduct the surveillance, you know,
Willy Nilly as as they please.
Um,
so it's figuring out exactly what,
what are the best reforms to meet that
objective of providing that oversight,
making it so that those warrants
are given, um, you know,
as needed and making sure that all in
all the information is being presented.
And again,
that that Fi's a court was initially
put in place to go after a tick to get
warrants, to conduct surveillance on
foreign targets. Um, not Americans.
And that's been one of the biggest
problems here with a lot of this mass
surveillance is it's collecting our
information as Americans illegally and
unconstitutionally because you can't do
that unless you go through this process
and you actually get a
warrant based on evidence.
What would you do about Julian the songs?
What would you do about Snowden? Uh,
as far as undoing, dropping the charges
president of the world, right? Yeah.
We're dropping the charges.
You dropped the charges,
but yeah,
they're still going after him
for something from Sweden, uh,
in Julian [inaudible] case.
Yeah.
And so Edward Snowden would be the only
one that you'd be able to write because
unless you would influence it, the charges
that the Trump administration is, um,
uh, putting on Julian
Assange's. Right, exactly.
And it remains to be seen whether or
not they will push for extradition.
There's another charge that was, I think
it was today, the Sweden decided to, uh,
go after him again for some
sexual thing that they had, uh,
decided to go after many, many
years ago. Um, Edward Snowden,
what he's doing right now is essentially
living day to day hold up in Russia in
hiding.
And w w the charges against him stem from,
again, this illegal operation
that he, in many ways,
he's very patriotic. I mean, he let
us know and at, at great costs. Yeah.
So you would give him a pardon?
Yeah, yeah. And I think address,
we've got to address why he did the
things the way that he did them.
And you hear the same thing from
Chelsea Manning, how there is not,
there is not an actual channel for
whistle blowers like them to bring forward
information that exposes egregious
abuses of our constitutional rights and
liberties. Um, period. I mean there's,
there was not a channel for
that to happen in a real way.
And that's why they ended up taking the
path that they did and suffering the
consequences.
There's a great bill hooks bit about what
happens when you become president that
they, uh, they bring you in a room
filled with smoke, cigar smoking buttons,
industrialists,
and they play a video of the Kennedy
assassination from an angle you never saw
before. Wow. And they say, uh, any,
any questions? And he had this bit,
and I thought about this bit when I
thought about Obama because Obama,
when he had his hope and change website
when he was running for president,
one of the things that they addresses
whistle blowers and how much they would
provide a platform for whistleblowers to
expose illegal activity that was still
on his website while he was president.
And while Julian Assange was
getting arrested. And while this,
all this was going down and,
um,
they wound up taking it down off of the
website. Once somebody pointed it out,
like, hey, you had this,
what happens when you become president?
What do you think
happens and why do these,
do you think that there are full of
shit and they're just saying what,
what we want to hear so
they can get elected?
Or do you think that there is something
that happens to them once they get into
office?
Do you think that it's possible that
they're given information that shows the
real threats at the world has and there's
things that the general public is just
not privy to.
And these are what influences people's
decisions to go against all the things
they were saying when they're running for
president. Yeah. Um, look,
I haven't been with them and I've been
in those rooms, so I won't speak for, uh,
for, for that, which I do not know.
But what I do know is this is
what happens when you have,
um, people who are elected to
serve in this job as president,
who's most important responsibility
as commander in chief.
And they lack the experience and the
understanding to be able to make the right
kinds of decisions that serve the American
people and end up even those going in
with the best of intentions
end up being very influenced,
whether it be by the military
industrial complex or the foreign policy
establishment that as we've seen over
decades has crossed both political
parties, both political parties in these
areas often end up making the very same
decisions about continuing
these wasteful regime,
change wars and acting as
the world's police. And, uh,
therefore I'm listening to them because
they lack that experience or that
backbone and understanding themselves
and then just continue the status quo.
Um, you know, Trump was somebody who,
during his campaign talked a lot
about ending the stupid wars,
talked about going after Saudi Arabia,
that they're the biggest supporters
of terrorism in the world.
And you know what happened now,
you know, and his administration,
what he called draining the swamp,
he's turned that swamp into assess.
You look at the people he
surrounded himself by, uh,
some of the biggest war hawks that our
country has seen. Guys like John Bolton,
people like Mike Pompeo,
people who've wanted to go to war
against Iran for a very long time.
People who have been cozy with Saudi
Arabia for a very long time. Uh,
you see who he's nominating
to be secretary of defense,
long time a defense contract
career men like over 30 years.
I think working for Boeing,
uh,
you see the kinds of people who he
surrounded himself by. And so it's, it,
it doesn't take a lot to figure out
how he has been influenced by them in
continuing these regime change or this
regime change is still going on in Syria
now.
Threatening regime change in Venezuela
threatening regime change and disruption
in Iran. Uh, and that's the difference.
That's the difference quite
bluntly between me and
other people who are running
for president is that experience and
understanding that I bring to be able to
walk into that office, to do that
job as commander in chief and uh,
on day one and to not succumb to the,
the establishment that,
that I have both felt the effects of as
a soldier as well as seen in action as a
member of Congress.
I'm going in with both,
both eyes wide open and understanding the
situation as it really exists and most
importantly understanding who I work for,
that I work for the American people.
Do you think with someone
like Trump radically shifts
his position he's doing so
because it's been influenced to change
his position because he's been given more
information or do you think they become
compromised when they're on an office
and they, I scratch your
back, you scratch mine?
Uh, I don't know. I imagine that
there's probably some of both,
but if you're,
if you don't have the strength of your
convictions and your understanding about
what kinds of policies actually
best serve the American people,
then you can see how easily you'd be
swayed and influenced by others. Uh,
you know,
you saw Trump's rhetoric on the campaign
trail about Saudi Arabia against Saudi
Arabia against the United
States support for Saudi Arabia,
calling them out for what
they are and now, uh,
refusing to end US military support for
this genocidal war in Yemen that Saudi
Arabia is waging that's created the worst
humanitarian crisis of our generation
because he says,
well,
he doesn't want to risk a multibillion
dollar arms deal with Saudi Arabia.
So you can see at least in that respect,
what he's really motivated by.
He doesn't,
he would rather continue to support
the senseless and devastating deaths of
innocent people in Yemen
and using our US military,
my brothers and sisters in the military
to do that because he doesn't want to
risk an arms deal with Saudi Arabia
theocratic dictatorship that actually
directly supports terrorist
groups like al Qaeda. Wow.
It's hard for people to
imagine that that's the case,
that it's an arms deal and they want to
make sure that this deal goes through
and that it continues to be financially
productive for both nations.
Well, that's, you know, and
this is Trump's argument.
He's like, well, you know,
that's American jobs building those
weapons that were selling to Saudi Arabia.
That's what's at risk.
My challenge to him and to the American
people is if the best our president can
do to help support the creation of jobs
in this country is to build weapons that
are being dropped on innocent
people in countries like Yemen,
then we need a new president.
We need a new commander in chief.
It will actually help serve the best
interests of our people and work towards
the interest of peace,
peace here at home and peace abroad.
Okay.
Yeah.
The idea that it's just jobs.
It's not just jobs. Yeah.
I mean there's consequences to these jobs.
Um,
you were talking about universal basic
income earlier and you were saying it in
regards to dealing with
impoverished communities, but, uh,
one of the big issues that people think
we're going to need universal basic
income for his automation.
Something that Andrew Yang has
built this whole platform on.
Elon Musk has talked extensively about it,
are in a situation where there was
an article today about Amazon, um,
using automo autumn, uh, these, um,
I forgot exactly how to describe it,
but essentially robots that are packaging
things and automation is going to
start taking over many non-skilled jobs.
And this is, that's true with the
travel industry, with trucking,
with moving things,
shipping that we're going to see less and
less of these unskilled jobs and we're
going to see millions
of people out of work.
And that universal basic income may be
the only way to bridge that gap between
them finding some sort of
viable new source of income.
Yeah, I think that's certainly part
of it. I think that's a, I mean,
it's a strong argument.
Uh,
we've got to figure out how we pay for
it and how it actually, uh, at, you know,
achieves that intended objective.
Uh, but also look at, um,
making that,
those kinds of investments in,
in how do you train a whole new
workforce and in what new areas?
So any you're taking people who are
working in, in, you know, really tough,
tough labor jobs.
You know,
you hear all these stories about people
who are working at Amazon very long
hours, very stringent timelines, uh, and,
and so if they're now being replaced by
automation or robots or whatever it is,
um, you know, let's look at our,
our economy and see how we can, um,
help train folks for, for jobs
that pay more money, uh, and,
and hopefully help offer
a better quality of life.
And I think that's overall when we
look at this. Um, I think that's,
that's the way that we
should be addressing this
is not just a job as a job,
as a job,
but really looking at the quality of
life of people in this country that a job
does not equal happiness or fulfillment.
Um,
but really looking at,
um, you know, parents who,
who have a child and who want to be able
to spend some time at home raising that
child or you know,
someone who wants to start,
start a small business and work out of
their home to be able to hang out with
their kids more or
whatever the case may be.
I think as we look at this and how we
make this transition in a positive way in
this country,
we've got to look at it from
this comprehensive approach.
Yeah.
The idea of these people that are working
in these fulfillment centers being
happy,
it seems pretty ridiculous.
They're not happy they have those jobs
as people are in back breaking incredibly
stressful positions where if
you read the reports, I mean,
I don't know how accurate their
reports of what the job is like,
but they literally run
from one place to another.
They're timed and they have
their own breaks or yeah.
Yeah. Time limits. Yeah. Yeah.
This part of the problem
with
the idea that companies are supposed to
constantly make more and more money as
you get Russo ruthlessly competitive.
People looking at the bottom line in
every single aspect of that business.
And one of the things that
suffers is human human sacrifice,
satisfaction.
And their,
their sacrifice has to
be greater because they,
they have to find a way to justify
their position in the company.
And so they get paid very little.
They work very hard.
Yeah. And now the wild placement
real company like Amazon. Yeah.
Paying not only paying no taxes when,
I think this is for the third year
in a row. Yeah. And also getting,
I think this last year was over $125
million tax credit that's on top of it.
Jeff Bezos says how much it was,
you got $150 billion and he's going
to give 75 to his wife and right.
The whole thing is ridiculous.
And it's what people who,
uh,
lean socialist point to when they talk
about unchecked capitalism without any
sort of regulation that can stop something
like that from happening and stop
workers from being exploited in that way.
It's just, and people say, hey, you don't,
you don't have to have that job if you
don't, you know, you don't want that job,
don't take it. But no one should have
to have that job. How about that? Yeah.
How about if,
if there's a job that makes you have
timed bathroom breaks and run from one
place to another, you should get paid
a fuck load of money for that job.
That job should be something that it,
it sucks all day long, but yeah, dude,
I make $5,000 a week and people are
like, what? Yeah, man, eight hours a day,
five thought you've got to run. But when
at the end of the, to save up your money,
man, you're making a lot of money that
way people would go, oh, okay. Yeah.
Amazon would still make a shit load of
money if they did it that way. But yeah,
automation barely making, I mean,
they're barely making minimum wage.
It's crazy. Yeah. I mean,
so that's where I think, you
know, as, as, as, and look,
this automation really changing
our economy is something that,
that I think we're behind the curve
ball on because it's already happening.
But let's try to see
the opportunity in that,
where if robots are going to start
taking over those back breaking jobs,
then then let's try to find, uh, you know,
new and innovative ways for people to
work and to earn a living that's actually
bringing value to them.
That sounds awesome on paper,
but how would one absolutely. That's
what we've got to work out. And it's not,
I'm not saying like,
Hey,
there's a government solution to this
and snap your fingers and it's all done.
No, the, I mean, this is, the government
has a role. I'd, private sector,
private business has a
role. Um, and we've got a,
we've got to work together because
this is all of our futures.
How ultimately imagined any potential,
any possibility,
any potential solution?
Well, I think there's, there's
pieces of it, right? I mean it's,
it's making sure that we close these,
these loopholes that tax loopholes that
allow companies like Amazon to get away
with paying no taxes and to get this
much money back as a tax credit.
How do they do that? Oh Gosh. I
mean our tax code is so complicated.
You know it has to do with the write
offs and how many years and depreciation
and all of these different things that
they plan for a and they exploit in order
to pay no taxes and to get money
back in return. It's just so easily.
It is and it's this crony
capitalism that's really at
the heart of this problem.
How, how do we, how do they
get that kind of sweet deal?
When you look at the
tax code that's written,
when you look at the tax
bills that are passed,
who are the people who are helping
influence and write those bills?
They're the big paid lobbyists that Amazon
has in Washington who are saying, hey,
this is something that we want to see
in there and working with lawmakers who
their cozy with to get
that legislation in there.
Well, this is one of the things that, uh,
has come out about Trump
over the last week or two,
is that he lost $1 billion over
the course of a x amount of years.
And that this is not really accurate,
but that this is how he set
like [inaudible] purposes
basically did basically
said it's sport is what you said is his
description was that it's sport. Wow.
So essentially he was
playing within the rules.
No one's accusing him of
doing anything illegal,
but the way he framed his taxes,
the way he,
Eh,
it turned out to be more than a billion
dollars worth of losses over a period of
something like a decade. Yeah. And
uh, you know, people were like,
what the hell is that? And
he's like, look, that's what
I was trying to tell you.
He was basically trying to say,
look,
this is something that I was telling
you people about when I was running for
president,
that the system is rigged.
I know because it was a part of the
rigged system and I paid these people off.
Yeah. Um, it is rigged.
But how could you get in
without getting assassinated?
How do you get in and say,
Hey,
all you billionaires that
are making all this money,
you're gonna make less money now because
of Tulsi President Tulsi is coming in.
There's a new sheriff in town.
Yeah.
Sheriff with an army of people
in this country mobilizing,
saying this government was
put in place to serve us,
to serve the people and as much money in
high paid lobbyists is these guys have.
Ultimately it is the people
of this country who cast
the votes and it ultimately
the people in this country who have
the power, if we choose to use it,
if we choose to make sure that our
voices are heard and that that is the way
that we make this change.
So would you have to simplify the tax
code? Would you have to make things
heavily simplify the tax code? And
you know, I'm working with my team,
we're doing our research to figure
out exactly what that would look like.
But I think we do have to simplify the
tax code because it is so many of these
loopholes and massive corporate deductions
that have brought us to the place
where we are today.
Where know most folks are not getting
any kind of meaningful deduction.
Most folks certainly are not getting
the kinds of tax breaks that these
corporations are getting.
Uh, because it's,
these corporations are influencing how
our tax laws are written and it's written
to benefit them. The, the ultra
rich and the 1%. And you know,
people who are working very hard
every single day are, are struggling.
They're still struggling just to get by.
What kind of dirty tricks do you think
they will pull out against you if you try
to fix the tax code and
try to make corporations
accountable and make sure that
they have to pay?
If they're coming after you now and
you're just making waves and get ready for
2020. I mean, it could be,
it can be pretty gross. Yeah.
Yeah. But I just, I, I don't
underestimate the power of people.
That's what I tell them,
you know,
and they've been playing these
dirty tricks for a long time. Uh,
there is more and more people,
I think,
in this country who are paying attention
and who are calling him out on it. MMM.
Don't underestimate the
power of the people.
You know what I think too? I think it'd
be better for them. Like Jeff Bezos,
you know, you fucking people over and not
paying taxes, Bro. That's so much money.
And I'm sure he pays taxes. I don't
know what he pays. But you know the,
the idea that Amazon's figured out
how to weasel that out, like that's
postures. You hear stuff like, you
know, Warren Buffet talks about this,
about he pays a lower tax rate than his
secretary, right? There's a famous line.
How is that? Because he has, look,
he's figured out all of these holes
within the tax system that he can benefit
from to pay lower taxes when most
people don't have that ability.
And as a business person
who is also fairly ethical,
you have to be perplexed or collect,
what do I do here?
Do I just do the right thing and give,
give more money to charity
and balance it out?
Or do I just take these cuts where
they are and let everybody know,
hey,
look how much money I paid
broken the system is the
shits. This shit's wack. Yeah.
I mean like ultimately what you're
saying, you know, as business owners,
whether they're small business owners of
these large corporations, I mean, look,
it is these large multinational
corporations that are
exploiting the system and
exploiting the people and represent
the worst of these crony capitalists
policies.
Uh,
and so when I talk about changing
this culture of leadership at the top,
it's bringing these values
of service above self.
This has to happen within our government,
but we as a society need to encourage
ourselves bringing these values of service
above self to our businesses,
to every sector of our community.
Because just because you run a business
and you make a profit doesn't mean that
you can't, uh, be a servant
leader and to think about, hey,
how can I make a positive impact? Yes.
For my employees and for their families,
but on, on society. On our
community, on our environment.
I think for the people that are running
these corporations, there would be,
there would be real value in appreciating
the fact that we're all in this
together. And you know, you're
not gonna live that long.
You just don't have that much time.
Nobody does.
Not even a hundred years if
you're lucky and you probably,
if you're running a corporation,
you probably on death's door, you've got
kids and you've got kids who have kids,
generations who will live
with the repercussions,
the decisions that are being made.
And the argument is that if you
forced them to pay more taxes,
then there's going to be less jobs because
they're going to have to make cuts.
Yeah. But that's, that seems
like a ridiculous argument to me.
One that's been made all along. It's
just you're used to it. That's all it is.
You're used to these loopholes.
You're used to it. So you
want to keep them there.
And if they take away those loopholes,
you're going to punish other people.
Cause you don't want to be
punished yourself financially.
That's what's really going
on. Yeah. And you know,
and this is coming from me
who's a financial dummy,
I don't pin spend any time analyzing
the financial situ situation this world,
but I could see that. Yeah,
that's pretty obvious.
It's glaringly clear and the impact that
it's having on people is also glaringly
clear.
People are seeing this and when automation
really kicks into focus and you know,
however x many years when millions
and millions of jobs go away,
we're going to be confronted with this
new world and this is what a lot of
people are very concerned with when they
talk about the next couple of decades
there.
They're very concerned with automation
and they're very concerned with audit,
our artificial intelligence,
artificial intelligence and that it's
not just going to take away skill are
unskilled labor, but it's also
going to take skilled labor away.
There's going to be no one
answering phones anymore.
It's all going to be computers.
They're very close to be able to do that
right now where a computer will have a
legitimate conversation with you and you
don't even know that you're talking to
a computer. It's crazy. It's crazy.
Are you concerned with sentient artificial
intelligence and in terms of its
military applications in
terms of, um, there's,
there's a lot of concern that what we're
experiencing now with particularly,
you wouldn't talk about Yemen with drones,
with these piloted things that you're
going to have is autonomous weapons in the
future where you just going to be able
to literally release killer robots.
I'm very concerned about
artificial intelligence and
how quickly this technology
is evolving, uh, with very little, um,
oversight or even understanding at the
highest levels of our government about
both what the opportunities are that it
presents and also the very real dangers
of this technology being weaponized and
how quickly that could spiral out of
control.
What could we do to stop artificial
intelligence from spiraling and spiraling
out of control in particular,
what can we do to stop autonomous weapons?
What a lot of people are really
concerned with. Did you watch that show?
Black Mirror? It's a great
show. It's on Netflix,
but a lot of it is dystopian stories about
the future and one of them was called
heavy metal and it's about
this woman being chased by
these little intelligent robots
that are trying to kill her. Yeah.
It's terrifying because this is something
that could be implemented in the
battlefield and we could have,
if we don't do it first,
we could have a situation where our
soldiers [inaudible] in some sort of a
situation facing off against robots. Yeah.
It sounds like a science fiction movie,
but it's not that far away from reality.
Yeah.
I think this is one of those things that,
um,
and of leaders in the global
community have to recognize that some,
some key just to, just like with
nucleus, the nuclear arms race,
once you start on this race, I mean, there
are no winners in a, in a nuclear war.
Everybody loses in that scenario.
And I think there's a similar approach
that needs to be taken to, um,
the dangers of artificial intelligence
being weaponized and coming together as a
kind of a global community to say,
Hey,
this is something that a
end date could potentially,
if putting the wrong hands in danger,
all of us and find the best approach,
um,
to deal with that.
Because my concern is as we see with
so many of these other weapons systems,
if it's just one country that's doing
it, then you have, well my gosh,
if everyone else is weaponizing,
but we're the only ones who
are doing the right thing,
then is that creating a situation where
our national security is at risk or our
troops are at risks? I think it's one
of those things that, uh, you know,
this world is a small place.
Uh,
we would have a shared interest with
leaders of other countries in the world to
provide the right kinds
of checks and balances.
I'm on this technology so that it doesn't
become something that's a danger to
humanity.
And the real fear would be that someone
would not think that at all. Yeah.
There would be whatever country,
figure out what the country is that
some country be like, fuck you,
we're going to do whatever we want.
We're gonna look,
you guys took over this world
because of nuclear power.
We're going to take over this
world because of autonomous
weapons and artificial
intelligence. Yeah. And we're going
to design it to go kill American.
Yeah. I think that that's why
it's important that we take, uh,
that we take a global approach to this.
Yeah.
And because otherwise I think you do,
you end up with that scenario
and where you just, you know,
this race begins and then there's
no way to stop it and it's too late.
Unlike China, the United
States has at least, yeah.
In perception,
uh,
cleared differentiation between
business and government.
[inaudible]
and one of the concerns that, um, oh,
when I've talked to experts in China
and their electronics and their,
their technological innovation is that
they're inexorably connected to their
government in some way, shape, or form.
And that it's one of the main reasons
that makes it incredibly difficult to
compete with them on a global marketplace.
Yeah.
When you see that this,
our State Department has told people to
stop using Walway devices cause while,
which is the number two provider
of cell phones in this world,
now they're connected to
the Chinese government.
Like how do you take that? What, what,
what do you do about that situation and
how relationship between the private
sector in government in particular
with the competition, what, look,
when it comes to data, I mean, we're
very concerned about people sharing data.
We've, we've done it
ourselves. We've spider,
we've proven through
the Edward Snowden case,
govern our government's
doing as well to us.
We're worried the Chinese are
doing it to us or so. And it's,
we're saying don't buy Chinese stuff.
They're gonna steal your data and steal
your information and still your business
secrets. Yeah. What can
you do to stop that?
What can you do to mitigate
what's already happened?
Uh, I, you know,
ultimately you can't stop every single
individual with what they're purchasing.
I think that, um, you know,
you can regulate what is, uh,
sold here in the United States.
Uh,
I think there's a role
that government can play,
especially as we're talking about
artificial intelligence and that kind of
technology, again, first in
understanding it and then playing,
um, being that responsible party, uh, too,
make sure that what is being developed
is not something that's going to result
in these, uh, unintended
negative consequences. Uh,
so obviously our government, uh, you know,
doesn't have ownership over
private business in this country.
We still do have sensible,
uh,
regulations and responsibility that
government has to play in regulating what
businesses can and can't do.
What's interesting to me is this
competition aspect between dealing with
essentially just the private
sector here in America. Yeah.
Versus the private sector in China that's
combined inexorably with the military
and that they have much more influence
over what gets done and how things get
done.
Um,
what did you pay attention at all to the
State Department's call for a boycott
of Walway products?
What did you think about that?
Uh, well, I understood it. You know,
I think there is a concern about that
technology being, um, being used to,
to get our information. Um,
you know, so that that, um,
can be enforced within the
federal government, right?
So if the State Department is saying,
Hey,
the federal government is not going to
purchase any Walway produced products or
cell phones or whatever,
the technology is a and encourage other
people in the private sector to do the
same.
What people were worried about over here
is that what they're trying to do is
stifle the development of this gigantic
company and that what they're trying
wowway yeah.
Of Wallet.
Because while we went from having a
tiny share of the marketplace about five
years ago to being the number two cell
phone provider in the world next to
Samsung, we just surpassed apple.
And that this is a Chinese company.
And that because it's Chinese companies
connected to the Chinese government,
the worry is that they're making ungodly
sums of money and it's enhancing the
Chinese government's ability to do,
to perform surveillance
or just to just compete,
just financially compete on a
global scale. And Tech nerds, um,
seemed to be siding with Walway,
which is interesting to me.
I've read a lot of tech blogs and people
that are experts and they say that
there's no evidence that these cell
phones have anything in them or,
or doing anything,
but that there has been some
evidence of network devices and it's,
some of these network devices do have
some sort of a third party input or some
building, some ability to extract
information that shouldn't be there.
That's interesting. Yeah. What this,
it's like when you're dealing with a
situation where you're competing with a
country that also controls these companies
that are the biggest cell phone and
electronics providers on the planet.
Yeah.
How do you handle that? Like what,
what is diplomacy with China like?
Well, we can see what's happening
right now with Trump. It's,
it's not working very well. Yeah. Uh, you
know, this trade war that, that frankly,
president Trump is escalating I think
is really, really dangerous. Uh,
it's having a negative impact on
domestic producers, manufacturers,
farmers.
A friend of mine is a small business
owner and he saw the news this morning
about China retaliating,
um, with Trump's escalation,
I think with, with another increase of
their tariffs. And how he's thinking like,
my gosh, that's going to impact my
small business. It got, I don't know,
probably less than 15 employees and
trying to figure out how it's gonna impact
the pricing and production, manufacturing
and everything every step of the way.
What's so dangerous about,
uh,
what Trump is doing with this
trade war that he is, um,
that he's escalating is that these trade
and economic wars can very easily turn
into a hot war.
And we're talking about a nuclear
armed country in China. Uh,
so while there are trade differences and
issues that we've got to address with
China and issues with intellectual
property and other things, um,
the way that Trump is going about this,
I believe is very
irresponsible and dangerous,
creating a huge amount of
uncertainty for American businesses.
A while increasing tensions with one of
the biggest nuclear powers in the world.
That's a scary thought.
It is.
[inaudible] and the ramifications of those
that could lead to a nuclear war that
this trade war could lead
to something military. Yes.
Yes.
What does Trump's argument is?
His argument essentially is that China
has been treating us unfairly and that
the rates that we're getting
there are there not, yeah,
they're not even yet. I mean, Trump
is recognizing a problem that exists.
That trade imbalance with China is,
is a real issue.
Why does that trade imbalance exists?
While,
I mean you can point to
probably a whole host of,
of issues and trade policy. I don't
think it's any one single incident,
um, that has, that has created
imbalance and that, you know,
I'm an Iowa a lot these days and a lot of
farmers have been struggling with that.
Um,
and would like to see it fixed a lot
in the tech community would like to see
these issues fixed, especially
related to intellectual property.
But the way in which Trump is doing it
is having a very negative effect on these
American businesses
and jobs that Trump is,
is supposedly advocating for both in,
um,
well really in the uncertainty that
that is being set where, you know,
it looks like they're on the brink of a
deal. Just the other day it looks like,
Hey, okay. The United States and China,
they've been working through these issues.
They're on the brink of a deal and all
of a sudden Trump sends out a tweet
saying,
nope,
we're going to increase these terrorists
from 10% to 25% and now China is left
like, okay. I thought we were, I
thought we were close to working,
working things out and now
left in a situation where
they have no other recourse
but to retaliate as they did this morning
so you can see quickly how this thing
is spiraling,
so out of control and increasing these
tensions between our two country not
being done in a way that
that to me is strategic,
providing us with the certainty of
that path forward to reach a specific
objective of correcting
this trade imbalance,
which is how this whole thing began.
Why do you think he's doing that?
Why would he make a cute look that it's,
it's hard to explain because
it doesn't make sense.
It doesn't actually serve us in our
interests of our economic interests of
meeting that objective. I don't know if
he thinks this is part of his masterful,
you know, negotiation skills, but
it's got a very dangerous effect. And,
and the fact that we have
nuclear strategists in this
country who remind us that
we are at a greater risk of
nuclear war now than ever before.
It's because of these kinds of things
that are increasing tensions between the
United States in China.
Uh,
other things that are increasing the
tensions between the United States and
Russia. You know, a country that we're,
we still have a nuclear missiles pointed
at each other that can be set off at a
moment's notice,
literally leaving us as people with
just minutes before a nuclear holocaust,
a nuclear disaster,
nuclear war.
And you really think that this could be
set off by these financial negotiations
and by Trump saying something
like that and just changing who's,
who's offering a tweet.
If you threaten a country's economy
and their economic security,
where does that logically lead?
You threaten their ability to, uh,
provide for their people.
You threaten their ability to
provide that stable environment,
which China so much of what
they do is just like, hey, they,
they look for that stability. What
else? What are the recourses there?
Other than the threat of military force.
And in this case,
when you're dealing with
two nuclear armed countries,
this is what's at risk and it's something,
you know,
it's hard for a lot of people to
conceive of like, okay, my gosh,
nuclear war really. I mean this
is something that, you know,
back during the Cold War
with the, the, the, you know,
kids going under their desk, these
drills and, and you know, okay,
where do you go find a bunker?
Uh, but this is something that,
that's a reality that we're facing
today. And it's something that, you know,
we in Hawaii in January of last year went
through with that missile alert. Yeah,
that was clear. It was terrifying. Missile
alert, nuclear weapons on it, right?
Right. Missile inbound towards
Hawaii seek immediate shelter.
This is not a drill.
That was the message that was blasted
out to over a million phones all across
our state on the radio,
scrolling across the television and people
immediate like seek immediate shelter.
Okay, where do I go? Where do I take
my kids? Where do I take my family?
Had College kids sprinting across campus
at the University of Hawaii trying to
find shelters, seek immediate
shelter. But the, the sick,
um,
insanity of all of this is that there,
there is no shelter, there is no
shelter and no nuclear bunkers,
which, which really, I mean, and for,
for people in this administration and
politicians who are ratcheting up these
tensions with these nuclear armed
countries bring us to this new cold war.
They are not saying, okay, well because
we're doing this, we're gonna Invest,
uh,
not just trillions,
but hundreds or thousands of trillions
of dollars to make sure that every single
American in this country has a nuclear
bunker within 10 minutes of their home or
their place of work or their,
or their school.
Because that's how much time we'd have.
That's what we would need in order
to deal with the consequences of the
decisions that they're making in the
failed leadership that they're providing.
And so this is,
this is an issue that I'm raising
awareness about because of what's at risk.
I mean,
this is,
this is the greatest threat that we face
and it requires strong leadership to
walk us away from this brink
of nuclear war, to be able to,
to work with other countries,
uh,
based on cooperation rather than conflict,
deescalate these tensions,
work out our differences and,
and walk us back from a,
walk us back from the brink.
Stop this nuclear arms race that's
making us in the world less safe.
The last thing I wanted to ask you
about was the opiod crisis. Yes.
And what are your thoughts on it?
This is an epidemic that is
continuing to ravage the country and,
uh,
we're not doing enough.
Our government is not doing enough
right now, uh, to solve it. Uh, and I,
I 0.2 to one,
a very simple thing that could drastically
help those who are dealing with
opioid addiction and trying to walk
down that path towards recovery.
And that is ending the federal
prohibition on marijuana.
There has been a correlation in states
that have legalized either a medical use
or adult use of cannabis, a
direct correlation in, uh,
a reduction of opioid addiction
as well as opioid related deaths.
This is one thing that Congress
can do now to help make progress,
uh,
in dealing with this opioid epidemic.
Another thing we've got to put a lot more
resources towards treatment on all of
the things that need to
happen after that detox,
that initial detox with folks who are,
uh,
dealing with opioid addiction and have
lost everything in their lives then or at
the place where, okay, well if they
have gotten through that detox now they,
they've got no place to live. They've got
no place to work, they've got no money.
And to be able to,
to provide that helping hand up as they
start to put back the pieces of their
life is something that we as a
society need to do a better at.
And the third thing I'll say is we've
got to go after the culprits responsible
for this.
When you look at companies like Purdue
Pharma who have intentionally deceived
and lied and cheated the American
people into taking these opioids saying,
no, you know, they're not risky, they're
not dangerous, don't worry about it.
These highly addictive opioids
creating this situation that we're in,
they are still not being held accountable
in the way that they need to. This,
this, uh, thing.
It's the Sackler family has made tons of
money off of selling these opioids that
have ruined and devastated people's lives.
Our legislation,
the opioid accountability
act we introduced in the
last congress we're going to
be introducing again soon would provide
our federal prosecutors with the tools
they need to hold companies like Purdue
Pharma and others responsible for this
proliferation of opioids
criminally, uh, accountable.
And another thing that baffles me is
this constant changing of the dosage.
This fentanyl in this new thing that's
even more powerful than fentanyl.
The fact that they're developing
these incredibly potent opioids,
the FDA has approved like,
I don't understand.
I don't understand why do you need them?
What are they for their there,
they're toxic. They're fatal and
incredibly small doses. Yeah.
And it's not like we don't
already have oxycontin coding. Oh,
we have all these pain medications.
Like why are they insisting on letting
these companies patent these superior and
even more lethal versions of something
we already have a problem with. Exactly.
Right.
It makes no sense. And I think
it speaks to the huge influence,
the huge influence that these
pharmaceutical companies
have over regulators and
lawmakers. Both. So much of
this comes back to money.
Joe, you say all the right things.
I love, I love talking to you.
I really wish all the best.
Thank you. It was, uh,
you know, it's a, we live in a
crazy time, you know, and uh,
your breasts breath of fresh
air. So, um, thank you.
I appreciate you and I wish you
well. Thank you. So good luck to you.
Appreciate it. All right, folks
on the road, good luck. Take care.